This is Jocko podcast number one 65 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good evening.
I've
said that war is the ultimate teacher
and I think it's also true to say that war is the ultimate revealer.
Yeah.
It reveals a side of people that would not normally be allowed to come out
cause in war there's so much happening.
There's so much pressure,
there's so much emotion
and it's all so intense and I saw people,
okay,
change.
Yeah.
And I don't want them to make this overly dramatic and in most cases,
I'm not talking about some big dramatic transformation that a person goes
through,
but I am talking about changes and the changes were often visible,
visible things that would be out of character for someone.
They'd start acting a different way,
sometimes negative,
and sometimes positive.
Okay.
There might be someone who's temper gets quick,
starts to flare up.
There might be someone that becomes more understanding,
more forgiving.
Okay.
Some people were happier in combat and some were just absolutely stressed to the
core.
And when I look back now,
it becomes very clear that there were some,
okay,
I'll call them oscillations in my own attitude.
Yeah.
There were some times when I had to reel myself in.
I definitely try and stay professional at all times.
That's kind of what I do.
I try to play the game.
I try not to get emotional.
That's just how I try and role.
Okay.
But
okay.
I could feel it sometimes starting to come apart a little bit and I would have
to breathe
mentally,
mentally breathe,
consciously pull the pieces back together
so
I don't lose my temper.
Okay.
I don't lose my composure.
I and I,
I know that that's good quality.
It's one that I saw other leaders in act and I thought that that was a positive
quality and it's one that I tried to emulate and I got pretty good at emulating
that quality,
but
sometimes on deployment,
okay.
I really had to focus on that.
I had to focus on keeping my composure.
I had to focus on not getting emotional.
I had to detach and tell myself to settle down and keep it together.
And it's not easy to do.
Then some people have a hard time doing that and they get short fused and they
lose their temper at the drop of a hat.
Once they're under the stress of
sustained combat,
others will not do that.
Others will go numb and they'll just kind of turn off and I tried to stay
balanced,
not to completely turn off my emotions but at the same time not get emotional,
but I had to think about that,
had to consciously think about that and there were other things that I noticed
about myself,
especially when I look back.
One thing I noticed is that the little things they do,
they really didn't matter anymore.
They lost things of little importance,
pretty much lost all importance.
If no one was dead and no one was wounded that things were going to be okay.
That's how it was for me.
And some people go in the opposite direction,
they start to lose their mind over little meaningless things and what they're
doing when they lash out in those situations is there.
That's how they're letting out the CV,
all encompassing stress that they're feeling.
Another thing I noticed is that I'm normally very tactful when I communicate
with people up and down the chain of command and it's pretty natural for me.
I've been doing it for so long.
I'm thinking about what I'm saying.
I'm making sure I'm saying the right things and that they're being understood
correctly.
I understand the importance of communicating from a leadership perspective,
but during combat deployments,
I can tell you I had to think a little bit more.
I had to put a little bit more fought into what I was saying because the urge I
was fighting against often was this urge just to be
offensively blunt,
just blunt and really even condescending or sarcastic or patronizing or snide or
mocking or cutting
because there is some level of madness in war.
There just is.
I mean,
let's face it,
you're going to go out and you're trying to kill people and they're trying to
kill you and your friends are trying to kill their friends and their friends are
trying to kill your friends.
That's not normal.
Okay?
That's,
if you take that out of context,
that's just madness.
Okay.
And that madness in war.
It can creep into your head and then very easily it can creep out of your mouth
if you let it.
And these were
okay,
all these types of things,
they,
they happen to me,
they happen to everyone.
I think I had a pretty good handle on it
and some people handle it better.
Some people handle it worse that the combat situations I was in,
there's people that have gone through infinitely harder combat scenarios for all
of mankind,
from the history of mankind.
Everyone in these situations is going to have to react to them in some way.
Everyone's going to be impacted by that madness of war.
Okay.
And like I said,
they're going to react in different ways depending on who they are,
depending on their background,
depending on their personality.
Yeah,
but the war itself is going to reveal,
okay.
It's going to reveal strengths and weaknesses.
It's going to reveal fears and regrets.
It's going to reveal ego and selflessness.
And when we see deaf,
when we face death,
and when our friends and our comrades are wounded and maimed and killed,
that has an effect.
And you might think,
how hard do I have to pull in on the reins of my own fury and hatred in a
murderous FOBTs?
Okay?
When young man after young man is sent home in a flag draped coffin,
I can tell you I had to pull in those rains hard
and I wasn't alone.
I was surrounded by men with the same vengeful farts.
But those thoughts have to be tempered and they have to be controlled or else
everything falls apart.
But those and
get revealed because of war
in war reveals things about us that otherwise might slip by.
Okay?
Thing is we might not want to share,
fought that we might not even know are a part of us,
okay?
But they are a part of us.
Okay?
And in the end,
war ultimately reveals who we are.
It reveals our nature and thereby reveals human nature itself.
It reveals our psychology.
And you can imagine that understanding all these different actions and reactions
from,
from your subordinate leaders,
from your commanders,
from your troops,
from yourself,
there's no way to effectively lead without some understanding of all these
people and their nature,
people that you must work with in order to accomplish the mission in order to
win.
And while that is crystal clear in a war,
it applies to every undertaking
replies to everything that you try and do.
Knowing the people you work with,
understanding the people you work with,
knowing and understanding your enemy,
knowing and understanding yourself,
knowing and understanding psychology and human nature.
And the better you can do that,
yeah,
the better you will perform as a team and as an individual
then,
especially as a leader.
Okay.
Andrew,
we spent the last podcast talking about the first part of a book called
psychology for the fighting man.
What you should know about yourself and others.
It's a very straight forward book
written in 1942 right as world war two was kicking off.
And on the last podcast we covered the early sections in the book
about things like putting the right people in the right jobs about the
importance of training,
about the best ways to teach and learn how to more efficient.
And today we're gonna dive into the second half of the same book,
which gets into some incredibly insightful
yeah,
and some incredibly revealing topics.
So let's
go back to the book
kicking off with this section.
And it's actually not the,
this isn't actually the second half of the book is probably the last third of
the book that we're getting into
and starts off with this section that's about morale.
Here we go.
Morale depends on the incentives to human action on men's motives,
on their emotions and how they react to their emotions.
It can be developed in a military unit by the control of those psychological
conditions,
which determine men's desires and conduct and affect their attitudes toward one
another and toward the great undertaking of winning a war.
And then it rolls into talk about incentives.
Some of these are pretty obvious starting off with hunger.
Hunger is a mess.
Call most sure to be heard.
Pain is an alert.
Seldom missed the most primitive incentives for action,
which man shares with other animals are his bodily needs.
Hunger,
thirst,
sex,
the need for rest when he is tired.
The need for activity when rested,
the desire to escape from pain,
extreme heat,
extreme cold and other intolerable conditions.
Okay.
It might be possible to control men are animals by the use of these incentives.
You might make a man go hungry until his work is done and then let him eat as a
reward.
You might make a man fight by lashing him and then letting up on him as a reward
for fighting,
but that isn't the way that our army works.
Whenever possible,
it supplies enough food and rest to its soldiers and makes other provisions for
their comfort so that they stay in good spirits and can do their work well,
but in areas,
but in fighting areas,
it's not always possible to provide these physical comforts when food or water
is short.
When the weather is too hot or too cold,
when it becomes impossible to bathe and shave,
when bombs and shells drive sleep away and fatigue makes a man,
it makes effort,
uh,
torture problems,
combat morale arise,
okay?
And then some other incentive is required beyond,
beyond their animal need to keep men going to make them determined to keep
fighting on two deaf
when the primitive needs are no longer enough.
It is the social incentives which help a fighting man do his utmost.
There are many social needs here are some of them.
So
interesting way to kick it off.
And those are so obvious.
We all know those things.
We all know that we,
if we're hungry,
we all know we,
we,
we try and escape from pain.
We all know,
we try and find comfort.
If there's discomfort,
I know you especially know that sure a little bit.
But when those things,
you can't always provide those things and it's,
you know what's really interesting?
We're talking about it's just words,
right?
It's just words in a book.
Talking about to make them determined to keep on fighting unto death.
Just words.
In a book right now.
But if you think about,
well,
this is world war two,
we're getting ready to go and hundreds of thousands of men are going to go and
fight and to the death,
and these primitive needs aren't going to be enough to drive.
So here's some social needs that people have.
Number one,
desire for social approval,
admiration,
recognition and appreciation.
Yeah.
To desire for security,
safety,
escape from danger and disapproval or fears of all kinds.
Okay.
Number three,
the desire for power,
mastery,
domination,
superiority and self assertion.
Number four,
desire for adventure,
new experience,
freedom.
Escape from futility.
Humdrum.
Number five,
desire for personal response,
companionship,
friendship,
love.
Number six,
desire to help and protect others,
especially the weak and helpless such as children.
Okay.
Number seven,
desire for a successful achievement.
Completeness.
Effectiveness,
the desire to do a good job.
Number eight,
desire to destroy interference with other desires,
aggression,
and rage.
That's uh,
that's,
uh,
it's when you hear,
when I'm reading that list,
I can think of little people that I've known and you know what was driving them.
Yes.
I remember thinking this.
So you think of,
you think of the military as a group of people even I do.
It's a group you think of,
Oh,
it's an army.
It's a battalion.
It's a brigade.
It's a company.
You think of it as a,
as a unit that's working together.
But what I will tell you is these,
these desires right here are so important for the conduct of warfare.
Because when you get down to a battalion level,
a company level,
platoon level,
there's an individual human beings that are driving that thing forward.
And if you didn't have a leader in charge,
or it doesn't necessarily have to be the platoon leader,
but if you didn't have a platoon sergeant,
if you didn't have someone in that organization that was going to drive this
thing forward,
it wouldn't go anywhere.
When,
when we do operations overseas and we'd work with the conventional forces
overseas,
there was a guy that was making these things happen that had,
that was driven by these types of things,
whether the weather,
some guy wanted to shine and,
and get,
get noticed and he's gonna take his platoon out.
Or whether he realized,
Hey,
the best thing I can do for survivability is to get aggressive and go take the
fight to the enemy.
All these,
all these things,
you can see where they come into play.
And you see the same thing in,
uh,
in civilian organizations when you see what's driving me.
You know,
you ever hear the question of like a rich person,
whatever that means.
But how much is enough?
Right?
There's very few people that become financially successful that go,
okay,
you know what?
I'm good.
Okay,
I've got two houses,
three houses,
I've got a bunch of really nice cars.
I've got a bunch of money in the bank,
I'm good,
I'm fine,
I'm done.
That doesn't happen very often.
The folks that they,
they achieve there and then they look up and go,
wait,
I can do some more.
And whether that's,
you know,
just completing a job,
like it says the desire to do a good job or the desire to help other people,
hey,
the more money I get,
the more I can give to other people.
Like these things are real and they really drive.
And so when you see a uh,
organization gets stagnant,
you got to look and say to yourself,
which,
how can we fuel this desire?
How can we allow this mission to answer some of these desires?
Going back to the book,
when a military leader calls a man by name and gives him a simple word of
commendation for some task well performed,
he's appealing to at least two or three natural incentives.
Calling a man by name shows personal interest,
which almost every soldier likes.
The combination is social approval.
If the soldier has been feeling insecure,
not quite sure of things than perhaps his sense of security is established by
the event of his leaders approval.
He also has assurance that he has accomplished a job well done.
That's the thing about that.
All it is,
and I've talked about that a bunch on here where I say,
you know,
sometimes leaders don't realize how powerful it is to say,
hey,
echo,
really good work on that last video.
Pete,
people don't realize her.
Hey,
echo,
really good job holding security last night on that position and I've said it's
powerful now it's here's why.
Here's some of the things that that feeds that person,
these desires that they want satisfied get fed when a leader steps down and
gives a combination that back to the book,
social approval is a strong motive in human affairs and in general.
Praise is much more effective than blame.
Combination can get results when bollings out fail.
By bowling's out,
they mean yelling at people.
Reproof tends to leave resentment.
It's just so smart.
Blame is often,
however effective when used in private and in moderation against a man whose
quality performances high for he will work hard to avoid such criticism.
I've always,
I had the luxury of oftentimes we're working with people where if they mess
something up,
if they got in trouble,
whatever,
you didn't need it.
I didn't need to do anything I could.
I could just basically say,
I heard what happened and that was enough.
Like they were just never,
they were never going to stop until they corrected that in my eyes.
Yeah.
I could see that
a man wants to count to amount to something to feel that he is worth while and
appreciated promotion,
citations and distinctions of all kinds of help serve this purpose.
Fear of the disapproval of others or some other form of punishment.
Works isn't an an incentive but is not as good as a steady thing.
Okay.
Troops coerced into action by a snapping Martin net become anxious.
Disgruntle jittery.
There is a loss and morale and initiative in judgment even in skill.
Okay.
Men Do better in groups whether fighting are working and one thing that's
interesting and we're going to get to,
there's a section in this part of the book called leadership and there's a
definite dichotomy and you can,
you can hear it here,
starting to talk about how [inaudible] sometimes it leans towards the
stereotypical military idea of like if I tell you what to do,
you do it.
But every time it leans towards that,
it counters it.
It counters it and says,
look,
if people don't respect you,
if you're not under,
people don't understand why they're doing what they're doing.
Like eat.
It always comes back to the true leadership.
Even though it it brushes up and it converses about some of the stereotypical
military leadership,
if it's certainly every time counters them with real,
true leadership back to the book of soldiers desire to do a good job.
His sense of workmanship has helped whenever he can be allowed to understand the
nature of the whole undertaking,
which he is contributing to which he is contributing.
Okay.
A successful leader never signs tasks blindly when he can reveal their larger
purpose.
By allowing his men to see the significance of their own smaller jobs,
he dignifies the lesser tasks by relating them to the large one.
This is always make sure your people understand why they're doing what they're
doing.
That's what it is.
Yeah.
It's a successful
leader.
Never assigned tasks blindly.
He mourns to make sure that the subordinates understand the nature of the whole
undertaking to which he's contributing.
This stuff is so important.
Continuing on morale is the capacity to stay on the job,
especially a long,
hard job with determination and zest.
It is the opposite of apathy.
Morale needs good health,
physical and mental.
Unless the body is well and vigorous,
it is pretty hard to endure hardship and keep up enthusiasm,
fatigue and illness,
PSAP,
mental vigor and more moral strength.
The body does influence the mind.
You,
everyone here that the body does influence the mind,
yet there is more to morale than that men can carry on with strong
determination,
sometimes even with zest through injury,
disease and physical privation
for that sort of morale.
A man needs self confidence and conviction.
He needs to feel sure of himself and emotionally secure.
While there are no simple rules for obtaining this sense of security and
confidence when the world is blowing up around your ears,
some of the conditions that bring it are known.
Okay.
It helps to have grown up in a home where there was no coralling or jealousy.
It helps to have friends and to be working or fighting in a group.
It is essential for the job to seem important for can be related to some of the
incentives to cumin action,
uh,
fought full man may need to see the job in its larger relations to fit into a
philosophy of life.
To make it a means of satisfying his own code of what is good and desirable.
He may need to take a long range view that extends beyond his own lifetime and
perhaps into another world.
All incentives to human action,
our potential morale builders.
There's a back and forth relation between work and morale.
Not only does morale make soldiers work in fight,
working in fighting,
keep up their morale.
Somebody in the last,
the last podcast,
somebody on Twitter just just hammered out quotes from this book and I was
reading them,
rereading them,
cause I'm reading this whole book and immerse.
We reading these quotes and there's so many awesome quotes in this book.
You could just make a book of quotes from just this book.
That's one of them though,
right?
Not only does morale make soldiers work and fight,
working in fighting,
keep up their morale.
It's 100% true,
especially in times of emotional stress as in battle.
Does a man need to to be doing things?
As for work alone,
men are not naturally lazy.
People like to work in forced idleness is a cruel punishment.
It has been shown again and again.
That person's with useful jobs to do in air.
Raids are unlikely to be afraid of bombs.
They are busy and the morale is good.
They carry on because they have important and useful work to do.
Actually,
they feel secure.
Even an air raid,
which is a strange place to feel secure,
it is the same with trained soldier in the midst of combat.
That stuff,
his brilliance right there.
That's brilliance.
That's why you have standard operating procedures.
That's why you have an immediate action drills when when you get attacked by the
enemy,
everyone knows what their job is supposed to be and it doesn't even allow them
time to be scared.
I have one
parachute failure where I pulled my reserve parachute and I got to the ground
and people,
oh you,
you know,
because all my buddies that I was jumping with at the time,
we were all kind of the same level except for maybe one guy that had a ton of
jumps,
but all my friends,
all my platoon mates were all,
bro,
you pulled your reserve.
And I was like,
yeah,
yeah.
And they were like,
Bro,
was it sketchy?
And I was,
you know,
I said,
I thought about it and said,
no,
I did what we trained to do.
You know,
arts look,
Grab Luke Rockhold pole check,
check.
I did what the procedure says to do.
That's what I was thinking about.
That's what I was focused on.
That's what I did.
So when you have something,
if I didn't have a protocol to follow,
it's like my bears are going to fail.
I'm going to die in 12 seconds or whatever it is.
Like you're dead in 12 seconds.
If something good doesn't happen real quick,
Brad,
it's not even 12 seconds cause you're at 2000 feet and you're fallen.
Yeah.
It's not very much time.
You're going to be dead pretty quick is what I'm saying.
And I didn't even think about it and I got to the ground and it wasn't my,
it's like my adrenaline didn't even move because you're doing what you're
supposed to do.
Yeah.
Like you and in you.
And obviously we're thinking about it,
not in the situation.
So yeah,
it's all scary.
I mean you pull one shoot,
it doesn't work.
And I'm saying outside of the,
the procedure,
the,
I'm seeing the facts of the reality of the situation you pull once you,
it doesn't work proof that parachutes don't work to you right then and there
proof,
oh,
if you want to start digging up your head real deep down thought but about
though and then now guess how many shoots you only have left one.
You already witnessed firsthand one shoot failed foreign,
this parachute jump,
you're 100% fail rate and you only got one more chance.
Yeah.
Within 10 seconds or whatever,
you know.
So really your brain is like,
yeah,
this is it.
You know,
if,
if you think of it that way,
but yeah,
if your mind is occupied with okay,
procedure,
procedure and then you just do,
do,
do.
And then it's like you don't have time to be scared about anything unless
they're,
you know,
if the second one fails then it's different obviously.
But,
um,
you know,
you,
yeah.
Your doesn't have room to start making all these,
uh,
these fearful assessments,
you know,
action
taking action is a real positive thing in so many situations.
When you start the feeling fear,
you got it,
do something,
you've got to step up and do something that's like,
you know,
in,
in like a Jujitsu tournament or w or whatever,
like a competition situation.
Um,
I would imagine it'd be like the CV if you're talking publicly or whatever
before you do it.
Like,
okay.
Before when I used to compete a lot in Jujitsu before I'm like,
oh my gosh,
like you're anxious and you just like,
the feeling beforehand is like way different than when was right when he says
start.
Once it started you don't,
we're just anymore.
Yeah,
which you do every day anyway and kind of thing and cause you know what to do
and that's what your mind is not and you're not feeling like,
even though you don't even know this guy,
he never even seen this guy before.
So you didn't know what mystery this guy holds.
You know?
I'm just saying that's kind of what you're thinking before you go on,
but once,
once you,
yeah,
for sure.
Hesitation is the,
is the moment that you have to overcome for fear and action.
We'll help you do that.
Back to the book.
If an officer wants to assess the morale of his own unit,
there are at least two things for him to do.
Okay.
He can listen.
Yeah.
Men will talk when permitted or encouraged to and they will some times speak
freely.
When they do,
they give their leader information that will enable him to answer these
questions.
Do the troops feel like they are being well trained,
well led?
Do they think their weapons are adequate?
Do they want to try and get the enemy?
Are they proud of their unit?
Do they have suggestions for improvement?
Do they have,
do they think they'd get fair treatment?
Fair chances for advancement?
Are they worrying about anything back home or what about what will happen when
the war's over from the answers to questions like these and officer can usually
estimate accurately the morale of his unit.
He can also study the behavior of his men.
Are they ready to volunteer for special duty?
Are they frequent?
Are there frequent violations of discipline?
How many are a wall?
How many in the guard house?
What is the rate of venereal disease?
How do they receive bad rumors?
Are there many fights and are the flights based on religious or racial
differences?
Morale building is the primary task of leadership.
Actually it says a primary task.
Morale building is a primary task of leadership.
The leader,
any leader trying to improve the morale of his unit,
we'll find these rules helpful.
So one of the main things you have to do as a leader is keep morale up.
No doubt about that.
If your morale falls apart inside of a team,
you're in a bad situation.
And here's some things to help you improve.
Morale.
One,
make each man feel he is needed by US unit that his job as important.
Two,
never let a man forget he is a soldier and that a soldier of the United States
army is an important and respected person.
Three,
make it very clear that the unit has its own important function in winning the
war for encourage the expression of pride in the achievements of the unit.
Okay,
five give commendation and encouragement when it consent,
when it can sincerely and appropriately be given for fair appreciation usually
works better than calm condemnation.
Six never belittle or humiliate a man in front of others except when a military
emergency as in battle may require quick correction when rebuke is necessary.
Do it in private and make clear,
make it clear that it is the act that is punished,
not the man.
Seven keep idleness at a minimum but make recreation possible little dichotomy.
You have to balance their train each man in every useful task and action that
actual combat will require and teach him that these habits will reduce his fear
when combat comms as well as make him a trained and able fighter.
Nine let men work together in groups whenever possible because the social
relation increases effectiveness and 10 but the soldier on isolated duty feel
that he isn't an indispensable man,
not a forgotten one.
Great advice there.
How often,
and this is something I've talked about,
I always,
the way I used to say this is ice.
I would say I want every person in my platoon think that their job was the most
important job in the scope too,
right?
I want the point man to think,
hey point man.
If you,
if you don't know where you're going,
everyone's lost.
You got the most important job and the platoon commander,
Hey,
this is your patrol.
You're the guy in charge.
You're,
they've got the most important job and the radio man.
Hey radiomen.
If something goes sideways out there,
it's you with your ability to communicate with air assets and other support
elements that are going to save everyone.
You're the most important guy and in the medic,
hey,
if someone gets shot year of the guide,
it's like I go right on down the line.
Everyone thinks and what's what's,
I'm not,
I'm not lying to them.
I'm actually telling them the truth.
I'm actually telling the truth.
In critical situations,
someone in that platoon is going to be the most important person.
It's not the same all the time.
I'm telling them the truth.
The truth is,
if you're the radio men and you're getting overwhelming enemy fire,
and that radio man can reach out and drop bombs on the enemy keys,
the most important guy in the platoon without question,
if you're trying to get to an extract point,
who's going to get to get your platoon out of there?
Then the point man is the one that knows where he's going and no one else knows
that point man is most important.
The person,
when you're in a machine gun fight,
when you're in a gun fight,
it's the machine gunners.
They go to lay down fire and allow you to cover and move and close with and
destroy the enemy.
It's the machine gunners most important.
You take away the machine guns and a soup,
then you've got a real problem on your hands.
So I'm not lying to anyone.
I'm telling him the truth.
The truth is that you have the most important job in this platoon.
Okay?
That's the truth.
And when people hear that man date's important to,
oh yeah,
okay,
and he goes back.
The book goes back in making sure that everyone understands how important,
what the,
what the unit is doing to the strategic victory and talking about pride in
unique expression that the,
we were overseas and like army units would have their battle streamers that they
bring from.
They bring historical documents and hang them up on the wall and they're in
their make makeshift op center
from World War II and hanging them up poster or paid newspaper clippings from a
world war two and they're hanging them up.
This is our unit.
This is what we've done.
We are upholding tradition.
We have pride in what we do.
So awesome.
Yeah.
It's a real thing.
Next little section is about zest.
Zested the fabric from which morale is made,
zest,
vigor of spirit,
love of life coupled with a willingness and eagerness to risk life itself in a
good undertaking,
a spirit of high adventure that turns a difficult mission into a rare chance to
show the stuff of which men are made.
This is the weapon that makes a military unit unbeatable.
Okay.
Think of a mission as a rare chance to show the stuff of which men are made
highly motivated.
Zest depends.
First,
upon physical fitness,
it demands a sharp appetite that will make a soldier eat plentifully and digest
his food.
It requires physical exercise that brings plenty of oxygen into the lungs and
plenty of red blood circulating to the brain and back to the hands and legs.
If a man is to meet the sunrise with any sort of spirit for the new day,
he must have slept at night,
sound and undisturbed by anxious dreams within him or by vermin in his bed.
Fatigue can quickly reduce a fighting spirit.
Okay.
The symptoms of mental fatigue,
whether in the air or on the ground,
are a staleness,
a lack of interest in the job to be done.
Lack of enthusiasm,
enthusiasm,
a heaviness of limbs,
eyelids,
even of the will that makes it well nigh impossible to drag through the day's
duties and with it,
shortness of temper,
irritability,
and for blues.
All leaders have to be constantly on guard against this insidious spiritual
fifth columnists among their men and among themselves,
regardless of how invaluable the man,
when fatigue is made at this attack on his fitness,
he must have relief.
He must be required to sleep,
to take respite from responsibility to get away from the strain he has been
under.
Otherwise,
the price is a psychological casualty and the more important demand,
the greater the cost to the army.
Okay?
Make sure your people are getting some rest as much as you can.
And again,
this book counters these things all the time by saying,
Hey,
there's some times where you're not going to be,
people aren't gonna be able to rest.
That's the way it is.
So then we should have to do is you have to understand,
you have to understand that that's what this book is about.
You have to understand now,
what are the risks involved?
Now we've got a unit that is severely fatigued and battle worn.
What are the risks?
They're not going to be able to fight as well as they did when they were fresh.
Hmm.
If you don't know that,
perhaps you send them in the front line to another battle.
If you know it,
you take another group that was in the rear and you send them the front line.
You let the guys that are fatigued to be the reserves.
That's why if the no one understand these things,
hmm.
Back to the book.
Excessive physical discomfort can also eventually deaden all zest for life and
for battle.
Men can fight with their socks,
stiff with dirt or frozen to their feet with hands,
so swollen and crack that they can barely pull a trigger.
They have fought when the baths are unknown and shaves are almost a scarce when
marching must be done through cs of mud and clothing never dries.
And when the eyes are cut and lungs are choked with never settling.
Clouds of dust and sand men have fought and are fighting under such conditions.
Okay?
But it takes an unquenchable spirit to keep execed.
When things are like this,
whole armies have shown this spirit,
but such conditions prolonged get zest in the end and therefore must be relieved
whenever possible.
When a man has his first encounter with the immediate threat of death,
when he must kill and see men killed,
when he must steal himself to hear the unheated cries of the mortally wounded
and endure the stench of battle,
a man may become sick in his very vitals.
He may lose interest in his food.
Yeah,
and yet this will be no sign of squeamishness.
The toughest of Leathernecks may feel intensely the inward revolting in horror.
The battlefield can provoke.
Okay.
The defenses against these physical and mental foes of the spirit,
our faith in good leaders,
a loyalty to them and to comrades and a shoulder to shoulder feeling of
solidarity with the other men of the outfit.
I can go anywhere and stand anything my captain and the rest of my outfit can
got to set that good example.
Fear ally or trader.
The first battle,
the first experience of having an enemy machine gun aimed at you the first time
an airplane swoops low to lay it's deadly eggs and your particular patch of
ground.
That is an experience anticipated by the young soldier with mingled dread and
eagerness.
He is eager by that time to get at the enemy.
He has learned a great deal about the science of war and wants to use this
knowledge to wipe out the enemy and gain victory.
But he always wonders every man does just how he will behave when the time
comes.
He doesn't feel like a hero.
If he is honest,
completely honest with himself,
he knows he will be scared,
terrified.
The experienced soldier who has been through all this the first time in many
other times has found out for certain that every man going into battle as
scared,
his hands tremble,
his throat is dry.
He must swallow constantly because his heart is in his mouth.
He does idiotic things like looking at his watch every few seconds or examining
his rifle a hundred times to be sure it is loaded.
The soldier green to battle may think he's the only one so disturbed,
but it is true of all the veteran as well
and it is true of the enemy.
Germans and jabs get just as scared as Americans and British.
The bad moments do not come during actual combat.
However,
but in the time of tense waiting just to be for,
as you just talked about,
echo,
as soon as the frightened man is able to go into action to do something
effective against the enemy,
especially if it involves a violent physical action,
his fried is apt to be dispelled or forgotten because he's too busy fighting to
remember it.
And this is great propaganda to talk about because what they're basically,
they're given this book to young soldiers that are getting ready to go and fight
and what they're telling him is,
look,
you're going to be scared.
Everyone's scared.
It's fine.
So that way they don't get scared and freak out because they're scared.
Airplane pilots who had distinguished themselves in action against the Japanese
said when asked whether they were scared during those moments of acute peril,
why?
I don't know.
There was too much to do.
We didn't have time to think.
Most were scared at first,
wrote a member of a torpedoed ship.
Sure we were.
But when the torpedo hit us,
we forgot all about it.
There wasn't much time.
And then there was much work to do.
It's another thing when you,
and it's going to go into this,
but when you're a leader and things are going bad,
give people something to do,
right?
Give them a direction.
Give them an order.
Say,
look our,
this is what we're going to do right now.
I don't know about that,
but what we're gonna do,
we're gonna move all these chairs and to get them into this world where you
know,
whenever you figured out something to do and do it.
Okay.
Encounters with the enemy are most terrifying.
When they are unfamiliar,
the soldier becomes used to gunfire,
the explosions and to the site and odor of death or sorry,
as the soldier becomes used to gun fire explosions and the sight of older side
and odor of death,
he gradually acquires the power to meet these things more stoically.
He does not actually lose his fear,
but learns to ignore it sufficiently to keep his attention mainly on the
business of combat.
And if he has in his train,
hands of good weapon,
which he knows,
we'll put the enemy out of action.
This gives him a feeling of confidence,
a sense of power that in large measure outweighs his fear.
He knows it will soon be the other fellows turned to be scared.
Okay.
Fear when experienced is intensely uncomfortable and seems to often to be
incapacitating.
If the period of fright is Paul prolonged,
a man may feel that his nerves are all shot by it.
For fear is disintegrating,
demoralizing.
It shatters morale.
The soldier may be rooted to the spot,
paralyzed or immobilized by fear.
Nevertheless,
such awful moments before an attack when each second seems an hour may actually
be useful to any soldier they may really add to his efficiency.
For fear is the body's preparation for action.
The heart pounds,
faster,
blood pumping more rapidly to the arms and legs and brain where oxygen is
needed,
belongs do their part by quick and breathing.
Blood pressure goes up.
Adrenaline,
which is nature's own shot in the arm is pro poured liberally into the
bloodstream.
Subtle changes in body chemistry automatically affected by powerful emotion.
Serve to protect the soldier.
Inaction in ways you would never think of if he had to plan them himself,
his blood clots more rec readily,
he loses temporarily sense of fatigue,
even though he may have been dog tired.
It is sometimes difficult for a tense frightened soldier to get started into
combat to begin the action will relieve his fear.
That part is taken care of by army training and discipline.
Months of training of taught the soldier respond from habit to definite battle
orders.
Even though in battle commands often cannot be given as in training,
it has become second nature to him to carry out his own job as a member of the
fighting team.
So there you go.
This is also important when you recognize,
when you know what's going to happen,
it allows you to not be scared that you're scared,
right?
So all of a sudden your breathing starts going faster and you feel the
adrenaline going through your system.
If you don't know what's happening and then it might,
it might catch you off guard.
Yeah,
but if you know what's happening,
well cool.
That's my adrenaline.
You know when you have,
when you feel adrenaline.
Actually go through your system,
like,
um,
let's say you're driving and somebody pulls out in front of you,
almost crashed into it too,
right?
And you can,
you can feel the adrenaline go down your arms and your legs or you felt that
before.
Oh yeah.
So if you don't have any idea what that is and it happens,
you might scare you a little bit.
What you know,
what it is,
you're kind of,
you're kind of good with it.
Yeah.
It's like you,
it's helped people.
I mean,
not enough.
I don't know the actual
process,
but you know,
Holly come,
yeah.
When you tense up before you do something right and you feel your heart beating
all fast and stuff like that,
if you know,
okay,
you know,
I'm,
I'm getting excited because of this event that's big in my mind or whatever.
But if you're like,
if you don't know or you're like,
what?
I'm losing it.
I feel like I'm losing it right now.
You know?
Like if you're,
I dunno.
Yeah.
And you know,
if you're about to go skydiving or something different for you,
obviously,
but the normal person before they jump out of an airplane,
you know?
Yeah.
Oh my gosh,
I'm losing it.
I can't.
And that's what a lot of the military training that you go through is to get
yourself,
hey,
when you,
when you start the fast road roping out of a helicopter,
when you're repelling off of,
uh,
off of the side of a cliff or out of a window in an urban environment,
or you're parachuting,
static land,
parachute free,
fall,
parachute,
all these things that you do when you first start doing them,
there's like an adrenaline rush,
but you just get used to it.
And so then by the time you're getting shit,
by the time we're getting shot at,
you're like,
oh yeah,
I know what this is.
I'm good.
Yeah.
I can carry on.
Back to the book.
No matter how distracted your mind may be by unfamiliar in terrifying sights and
smells and sounds,
you act from sheer force of habit.
In fact it is habits which take care of a man.
If he is too frightened to think clearly like the habit of diving for cover when
bombs come down then presently you are an action.
You are fighting.
Okay,
you are at last using your force against the foe.
No more are you a depressed,
frightened soul,
fears,
forgotten,
provided your well trained
good to teach people the how to respond in certain situations like he didn't.
You know when he comes to the self defense,
hey if you get attacked,
here's what happens.
Here's what you do when they just have that plan that's worth a lot.
Just having a plan is worth a lot.
Somebody grabbed you here,
this is your reaction.
Somebody grabs you there.
This is your reaction.
You know those things they if you see him out of context,
like if you watch ah Gracie defense video out of context,
you'll say well it's going to be hard for that particular movie.
It's if you go watch like a mic Dojo,
self defense,
then you go,
that's just the,
obviously that's never going to work.
But even you watch a Gracie self defense thing out of context,
you don't understand it.
You might be like,
well,
I don't know how that's gonna work,
but it's a
plan that you're going to take action and it is an effective plan.
By the way,
it's not like it's not a good plan,
but the fact that you are going to immediately take action,
you're going to respond to the event immediately.
It's going to put you in a totally different place and a much,
much infinitely better place.
Then I just got,
you know,
someone just grabbed me by the head or by the arm and I have no idea what to do.
That's a bad situation.
Then that fear is going to rise.
If you have a reaction,
boom,
you go and action and then the,
he talks about like training,
right?
If you,
you know,
the well trained person,
it's like you're just so fun because training is just like repetition rate,
all these different scenarios,
so you're so used to it.
It's like nothing new.
You're so used to this stimulus or,
okay,
remember when you're in elementary school,
they do a fire drill every whatever.
Then you just calm,
lead,
stand up and walk out in a single file line.
You know,
it's like,
it's kind of boring in a way,
but I mean,
we'd never had a fire in my elementary school,
but I'm imagining that if the,
once you heard it was a certain speed is a specific belt that went on it instead
of the regular bill,
it would go ding,
Ding,
Ding.
It was obviously a fire drill,
you know,
when you heard the bell.
So it was so ingrained in,
well in me anyway.
I'm sure everyone else felt the same way as a kid.
Um,
when you heard that you were like,
oh,
you just sorta automatically like a Zombie stand up and line up.
Like,
you know,
it was almost like,
yeah,
I was like so automatic.
So I'm assuming that like if a fire actually happened,
your instinct would be to do what?
Just do it normally you wouldn't run and scatter and be all crazy or whatever.
You'd just,
cause you're still quote unquote trained just to do it,
you know,
completely.
I guarantee if you look back in the history of school fires,
at some point there was a school fire before they did that training and everyone
panicked and freaked out and people died.
Yeah,
well maybe people didn't die,
but people said,
Ooh,
that could have gone bad.
And so then,
oh guess what you do,
you rehearse it,
you trained this bell means stand up moving this direction,
go out this door,
assemble in the recess area for head count.
Yeah.
In fact,
I remember in college someone pulled the fire alarm.
It was,
it ended up to be a praying,
but everyone's sorta thought that,
oh,
this building is on fire.
Right.
It was in the middle of the night.
I don't think I've ever believed a fire alarm in my whole life.
And I'm trying to think if,
no,
wait.
I've been in one situation where there was a legit fire,
but I was like completely.
Everyone just thought I was super cool and calm.
But I was actually,
and then finally I was,
yeah,
we needed to get out of here.
But yeah,
most fire,
cause you think about,
I've experienced a lot of fire alarms and yeah,
there's a very low percentage of them that were real fires.
Yeah.
And that's,
well,
I mean I guess that's an added element though.
Like if,
if your train,
but you never think
it will ever,
ever happen.
I don't know if the,
I would think that'd be a little bit different because almost like you run the
risk of when it actually does happen and you smell smoke or see the smoke or
have see the flames of whatever that might introduce an added element that you
weren't expecting,
you know?
Yeah.
So that might jam you up.
But nonetheless,
I think like when you go through,
like I remember there,
there was a fire,
but it was like way in a different building and it was just procedure.
Everyone evacuate,
you know,
kind of thing.
And we found out it was just later or whatever.
So,
yeah,
I don't think I ever had the stimulus of the fire,
but in college or whenever,
when,
when I did think that it was on fire,
I didn't hear it.
Or I mean I didn't smell it or see it or nothing like that.
We all are thought,
obviously we're in no threat,
but because if there's no fire around you than you think.
Yeah.
That time to get out.
But it was still the same.
Like no one was panicking,
it seemed like,
but I'm just saying there's no,
there's no,
like what we're talking about here,
there's no incentive to run because it's just the alarm and you follow the
procedure.
Yeah.
Well yeah.
And then if you,
let's say you're just lining up in a single file line commonly cause you're
supposed to do it calmly.
Meanwhile,
the guy behind you is like choking and getting busy.
Sure.
It's on fire.
Right.
You're going to run straight up.
I might try and help him actually the old stop,
drop and roll.
It's old school.
Yeah.
Running.
Well Bro,
the fire.
Good point.
Right?
It goes into some specifics here,
how to fight fear.
One action dispels fear,
do something and the time is suspense.
When men are all ready for action but are waiting for the signal to start,
fear is at its height.
If the period of waiting is prolonged,
perhaps delay until uh,
uh,
weather changes.
The time should be occupied with preparation for action.
Fight fear with necessary or manufactured work when expecting combat,
when waiting for enemy bombers to return manufacturer at work.
Like,
Hey,
you just got to make something up for people to do.
Seems it seems.
Yeah.
Huh.
And he is not hard in combat.
There's always something to get ready.
Right?
So he's not hard to say.
All right.
What we're gonna do is we're gonna set up a couple other bunkers.
Let's fill some sandbags.
Cool.
We're all working.
There's always a reason you,
it doesn't even have to be manufactured.
It can be real to physical contact with friends helps men shoot if at all
possible.
Stay with inside of in time of peril but not bunched up enough to become a bomb
target.
Just the presence of another man not far off with no when no word is spoken.
Minimize fear.
Three roll calls help men.
Imperils should be reminded that they are not alone for knowledge is power over
fear surprises.
The most important element in battle bus men should be constantly kept informed
of the dangers they may meet.
That one can be a little bets.
A little bit of a tricky one because
yeah,
sometimes people would get a little freaked out when they would hear about what
the enemy can do.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I'll tell you one thing.
When when when we were in Ramadi,
it was a lot of ideas,
a lot of ids and when,
if someone would come to visit us,
okay,
we and they wanted to come on an operation with us,
we would give like the slightly longer IED brief so that they understood the
threat.
It wasn't always helpful for them.
Psychologically.
You could see as the brief went on,
you could see,
I would watch the reactions on,
on people's faces and you could see them start getting really concerned because
it's just,
you know,
my EOD guy standing nodes,
here's the bomb,
you know,
from,
this is what it did to this vehicle yesterday.
This is what it did to the de vehicle day before.
Here's what,
here's what it looked like.
Here's one that they found.
Here's what they did.
And it was just,
you know,
slide show of bombs in the city that you're about to go into,
which is not a big city.
It's,
it's two miles,
three miles across snot like we're going and there's a small chance,
and by the way,
there's seven to 10 IED detonated a day on Route Michigan,
one road going across your body.
So it was when you tell when people would come to Ramadi and they'd get that
brief,
he would always be sort of an interesting look on their face.
I would see people tapping their toe shaking their leg,
you know what I'm saying?
You know what I'm saying?
It's like a nervous thing.
I would watch for that and I'd see people just getting all nervous because hey,
it's a real thing.
I mean I get it,
but the guys from t bruiser,
we're kind of adjusted to it.
You know,
they were adjusted to it.
Back to the book,
control of action helps to be afraid.
Does not mean that a man must act afraid on this one.
So good to be afraid does not mean that a man must act afraid.
Fear is contagious.
Winded is expressed in action.
If a man goes to pieces and becomes panicky,
he must be removed from the site of other men.
If that is at all possible,
it is each man's responsibility to control the signs of his own fear if he can
so as to spare the others.
If he can manage to act as though he were calm,
he may actually become more calm.
Okay.
At any rate,
the opposite of true is true.
Giving into fear tends to increase it.
Okay.
There you go.
It's straight forward.
Don't be shaking your leg during the brief.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Don't show that you're scared cause that gets contagious.
And other people will start feeling like your,
you've got to act like no factor.
Whatever you think they can blow me up.
Bring it.
Yeah,
bring it.
You can't be panicking and freaking out and each man is responsible to keep
themselves in check,
keep their fear in check and just cause you're afraid doesn't mean you get to
act like it.
Cause I kinda like when when your kids get older you,
well you and your kids get older,
you have to have that conversation with them.
You know I have that conversation with the law.
You don't get to act like you're scared.
You don't even get to act like you're mad.
That's why we play normal face.
You don't get to act like that.
You think you're going to get hit in the head with this thing.
Cool deal with it on the inside.
You know like when your kid,
when they're young,
young and they fall down.
Right.
Your kid,
your son,
daughter,
whatever,
they fall down.
Best thing you can do laugh at them or,
yes.
And it's funny cause there was,
that was awesome.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a good one.
That idea,
but there's that split second.
When they fall,
they're stunned.
They're shocked and they look at you with like,
how am I supposed to act right now?
If you're like,
Ooh,
good,
run up to him.
Oh my gosh,
are you okay?
I think it's there every time.
That noise that you just made is,
is my wife is the absolute greatest at this time.
She can make a grown person make you think that you should start crying and
freaking out because she just gives the
cause for alarm.
She causes so much alarm.
Married to her for over 20 years.
Yeah.
And we'll be driving.
Oh no way.
Where we're not,
we're not talking like a rainstorm on the highway going 60 miles an hour.
We're talking just cruising,
just through like a normal area and I'll just speak no relaxed thinking,
paying attention all of a sudden.
And you know what she'll say at the end of it and she'll go look at that.
Cool.
And I'm thinking,
can you know,
I've been telling her not to do this,
but it's an instinct that she has.
It's a,
it's an instinct that my wife has
and it's,
and now,
you know,
my son doing his driving,
like he got his license so he can drive.
Oh.
And he came home the other days like,
man,
he said,
Dad,
I'm driving with mom and then it's kind of scary.
And I'm like,
why?
What did she do?
I was thinking she was driving.
He goes,
no,
I was driving,
but I drove by like,
uh,
road and she,
oh,
I can't do,
don't act scared.
Don't do it.
And,
and for some reason my wife's,
that's,
that's an emotional noise that she makes.
It's not fear.
It's like excitement,
everything.
Sometimes it's like I see something cute too,
just so,
I mean,
I see something.
Why would you do this?
Or if you see cute,
why
would you go?
Don't do that noise.
Yes,
the wrong noise.
That noise means I'm about to get in braced for impact.
That's what that noise means.
Noise means I'm about to get t boned and I have a split second to accelerate out
of the kill zone.
That's what that noise means.
It doesn't mean look at that cat,
stop it please.
I don't know if that's it.
A life thing or what?
Cause my wife is the same thing.
Same Way and it actually is exactly what this book said where you get like act,
act scared because it will cause other sax scared essentially right now induce
panic,
whatever.
Which cause that's what it did.
That's what your wife for sure to you.
That's what my wife does to me when she's like,
like on the computer and she's like,
oh.
And then I'm like looking around like,
oh what's that?
Clearly we're all about to die in the next 15 seconds cause we just made that
noise.
Exactly right.
And that's kind of what goes off for a split second.
I wonder because I should have been able to deprogram myself and I have a
little,
I have a little bit,
but it's not full.
It's not a full deep program.
When I hear it,
I still think imminent threat is within 14 seconds of impact,
if not three seconds.
Especially when it's out of nowhere.
Like,
oh,
it's totally out of new is,
you know,
we're just driving.
It's a sunny day.
Everything just looks
so bad.
Don't make that noise unless you're,
unless you see a person with a machete and it gets in the striking position,
they'll make that noise.
Cause that's what I think.
I think.
I think Freddy Krueger's with behind me with uh,
with ready battleaxe getting ready to take my head off.
No,
I don't know.
Here they have a battle ax.
Weird fingers.
The Nice on the fingers.
But yeah.
Dang.
That's,
yeah,
good advice.
100%.
You can't,
I don't know how much you can train yourself with that though.
That's,
no,
I think that's a,
I think that's a genetic programmed noise that heightens the reaction and
prepares you for combat situations.
Cause there's like some reason it's morphed into this thing where it can also be
triggered to make that noise by a cute cat cans.
You know,
whatever.
Yeah.
Or like maybe she forgot something,
you know.
Oh yeah.
That's another one.
I forgot her to tell you.
Oh,
you know,
our friends are having a baby or something like this.
You know?
No,
we won't even be that.
It'll be like,
I forgot to tell you.
I got Billy coming over to work on,
you know,
yard sprinkler.
Okay,
cool.
Thanks.
Now that my adrenaline is through the roof,
that's going to happen.
Check back to the book.
There's another kind of fear that must be endured for days and weeks,
perhaps months or years.
If men are besieged cutoff from help,
deprived of adequate,
deprived of adequate defense than the ever present peril from the enemy may be
aggravated by the greater peril
of disease,
famine,
exposure,
and there may be little chance for action.
Men and the president wore,
have endured primitive sorts of hardships that would seem to be beyond human
endurance in Bhutan on Corregidor alone on a rubber life raft for five weeks and
blistering sun and drenching storm without food,
without shelter,
without water,
without any aid,
but their own unquenchable spirit,
their fortitude and their faith.
This means terror mixed with despair.
The misery cannot be relieved.
It can only be endured then they must maintain sanity,
courage and life itself by their ingenuity in originating occupations for hands
and minds that were leave the tension and seem to reduce the hazards.
And this is the kind of stuff that captain plumb talked about,
figuring out stuff to do,
like just we're going to figure out stuff to do,
whether it's,
whether it's make,
teach herself calligraphy by making an ear wax,
a re,
uh,
etch a sketch
or whatever.
I mean these guys,
those guys figured out things to do back to the book and such trying times and
intense moments.
All laugh can be a lifesaver and army officer relating experience of the World
War.
That's the first world war.
It tells him what time when badly frightened untrained soldiers of that warrant
taken refuge in a roadside ditch against an unforeseen horror.
The fire of American guns turned on them by mistake.
Panic sent the blood pounding into my head and emptied my stomach of courage.
It was bad enough to be shot at by the Boesch,
but there was no sense in being killed by friendly troops.
My men look wild and fingered their triggers,
ready to return fire of our other battalion.
Something had to be done and done quick and captain wast did it unintentionally,
but he still did it.
Jackson,
he yelled,
yes,
Captain,
where are you?
Right here across the road.
Stand up so I can see you.
Captain Jackson shouted above the crackling roar of machine gun bullets.
If you want to see me,
you stand up.
American humor can lick anything.
The smothered chuckles ran down the line orders were given and listen to men
wriggled backwards out of the zone of fire.
The first to reach the trees dash down the line with third battalion shutting
off the guns.
So you'll get to hear jokes like that and it is helpful
continuing the soldier who deliberately chooses to be blown up in order to wipe
out an enemy tank or machine gun nest that would have otherwise cost the lives
of his friends as ideals,
as indeed all it takes to make a soldier the commander of a ship who Cooley
sends away the last lifeboat and goes down with his vessel rather than abandon
it while some of his men are helplessly imprisoned in one of its compartments is
afraid but governed by something more powerful than fear.
That's a good statement,
isn't it?
Governed by something more powerful than fear.
What kind of governance do you have over your own emotions?
That's a good question.
You may call this force idealism,
conscience,
religion,
philosophy,
tradition,
code,
or even habit.
Okay.
Or you may be modern and call it ideology.
Psychologists sometimes call it the triumph of the social over the selfish
instincts.
They recognize this force as the most potent weapon and army can possess men
fighting for their homes and armed with this spirit can stand their ground and
win against tremendous opposing forces.
Next section.
Why men fight lower animals fight from a variety of causes,
some fight because as be slippery,
they live by killing and devouring.
Animals may fight their own kind in a tussle over a mate.
They fight to defend their young,
their homes or their own lives.
Some are aggressive and go about seeking what they may devour.
Others fight as a last resort when they're cornered.
Men being two legged animals may fight for any or all of these reasons,
but because they have minds capable of being moved by abstract ideas such as
honor,
glory,
freedom,
sympathy,
justice and patriotism.
Men also fight for what they believe to be right greater than fear of injury and
death.
Napoleon said is the fear of shame.
Before a drafted man throws himself wholeheartedly into his work as a soldier
before the civilian makes up his mind to enlist in the army he has stirred by
he's stirred in influenced by one or perhaps many of the following forces.
He may be carried away by men.
This is Jesus laying out why people are in the army.
And this is important to understand.
If you're a leader of a bunch of people in the army and you've got to understand
how they ended up there.
So if you're in charge of a company,
you got to understand well how people ended up in a position where they're
working for you.
Why?
Why are they there?
How'd they end up there?
He breaks it down for people that join the army.
One he may be carried away by mass suggestion
and infectious martial spirit spreads through the community roused by government
officials,
speakers or writers.
Flags are waving,
bands are playing,
drums are beating and crowds are cheering.
Boom.
Two,
he may become involved in a wave of war.
Hysteria like the fervor love,
martial spirit,
war hate is infectious.
Men rush to arms at news of the enemy's evil designs or brutalities of a
treacherous assault or intended innovation.
Three he may be urged on by s strong spirit of adventure for the ambitious self
centered man,
especially perhaps if he has been unable to achieve success in civilian life,
may see war as an opportunity to gain personal glory and power.
Five he may be driven
by his own combativeness.
Some men delight and fighting for its own sake.
Some may even be killers at heart because murder is outlawed in civilian life.
And because in many circles,
even taking a poke at a man or cursing him freely is frowned upon.
Some combative men may find their first thrill of release in an attack on the
enemy.
Six he may be unconsciously trying to relieve a grouch by violence that is
considered legitimate.
The man who has spent a lifetime in during unending series of disappointments,
failures,
and obstacles,
and who is damned up in himself over every mountain grievances and resentment
may be able to turn all that ill will against the enemy.
Seven he may have joined the army as he would apply for a job.
So the thing about the stark difference between those couple there who got one
person that just wants to fight people and one person that feels like they've
been a failure and everything,
it just kind of has an opportunity to take that grudge out against the world.
Right.
I'm a murderer at heart and you've got another guy that,
hey,
I joined cause this is,
hey it seems like a good job.
They get to pay my GI bill or whatever.
Eight he may be.
He may have been driven into army life by regard for public opinion.
He may feel keenly the way his friends,
especially the girls regard a military uniform and a fighting man.
He may hate the thought of being considered a slacker
nine it may be his desire to maintain his own self esteem that moves him.
He may have to end his secret.
Shame at the thought that others are doing the fighting forum.
Ten eight his action may be based on a feeling of oneness with the nation and on
faith and leaders in the nation's leaders.
11 he might be acting out of his faith in democracy.
12 he might be compelled by his spirit of sacrifice.
All these reasons why men joined the army,
why they accept training in many cases,
why they keep on willingly,
willingly.
When they go on overseas to a fighting front
yet by the motives,
by then the motives usually change or some of them do and here are the chief
chief reasons why a man of fights at the front.
So there's a little difference here.
So this is why they joined and now it's why they're fighting and this is
something that you hear about this kind of a,
it's a kind of a cliche thing you know is fighting for the guy who's left and
two is right,
this is this.
We're going to go into it a little bit cause that that is what it is and it's
true.
13 in a unit with good morale,
he fights out of loyalty to his comrades in his unit.
Boom,
there it is.
This is important though.
14 or he may fight because he is led men at the front face danger and are often
uncertain what to do about it.
This is especially true in a unit with uncertain morale.
It's like I said earlier,
like sometimes the leaders,
if you've got a good leader that's going to make things happen and could make
things,
hmm,
this is a good one.
In 15 a finally a man may fight because there's literally nothing else to do.
Okay.
And of course everyone uses the word literally now,
literally time.
And if you take it,
if you remove that from your brain to to make literally mean what it's supposed
to mean,
think about the sentence.
Finally,
a man may fight because there is literally nothing else to do.
He and his comrades are in the war and at the front in battle,
no one stops to figure out why he should escape from a burning house.
So with fighting.
So yeah,
there's some people like,
oh yeah,
yes.
What?
You have two choices,
fight or die and you're going to fight.
Yeah.
How men meet defeat the way a man stands up to a blow part.
Leave course depends on how heavy the blow.
When a man is faced with a very difficult problem or a series of them with any
sort of obstacle or frustration,
when things become too difficult or three sorts of things he can do,
he can work at it harder,
attacking the problem from new angles with increasing vigor.
He can get mad and attempt to destroy the obstacle or himself or something else,
and three,
he can give up in despair and runaway
in apathy.
The first way is the way of learning.
Right?
Okay.
When what seems like a good plan is hit upon it is tried.
If this fails,
there's a signal for more thinking.
When a good working plan is finally evolved,
success is achieved and the man is learned,
so that's,
that's the best thing to do.
Right?
You tried different solutions.
Yeah.
All this activity is healthy and less the individual.
Oh,
there's a little balance.
There's a little dichotomy here.
All this activity is healthy unless the individual become so engrossed with a
single problem,
so obsessed by it that he fails to eat or sleep or pay attention to other
necessary problems,
can't get target fixation.
Hmm.
Getting mad over disappointments or failures is generally not profitable,
is particularly hard on the innocent bystander because of the way men have of
shifting their grouch from the original obstacle to other persons or things.
The man who fails to get a promotion he has been working and longing for,
doesn't take a poke at the officer who refuse to recommend him.
Much as he would like to have it out with him and said he's likely to kick his
buddy in the pants so much that he raised,
if he's so much as raises an eyebrow leaders to make take it out on on offending
men who then wonder what's eating him.
Okay.
Aggression may also be turned inward on to the self.
Many a man goes about kicking himself usually figuratively,
but sometimes in real self punishment such as the head or punching or kicking a
hard object until the flesh is bruised.
Of course the extreme of self punishment for disastrous failure or frustration
is suicide,
but mostly suicide is just giving up.
Okay.
If at first you don't succeed,
try try again.
This adage may be used to maintain courage,
but the process is actually governed by natural law.
The number of times man will attempt to accomplish a certain job or to reach a
certain objective is governed in one direction by the importance of that
particular success and in the other direction by the effort and pain involved in
trying.
When the successful achievement means less than the individual to the
individual,
then the freedom from the strain of trying to attain it,
any man will abandon the struggle.
Giving up is nature's way of protecting the organism against too much pain,
so that's my don't.
Once you've banged your head against the wall 44 times,
that's enough there.
You're not going to get through it on the 45th or the 46 of the 47th track.
You need to find a different way.
[inaudible]
that goes on.
Giving up may mean defeat.
Yeah,
but it does not always mean surrender.
In most situation.
What has given up is some particular way of reaching the goal rather than a
complete abandonment of the objective.
This sort of defeat results in thinking in fresh striving in eventual progress.
A man who has been unable to get a commission in the army main list,
earnest stripes in later reach an officer candidate school,
another kind of giving up results in compromise.
The original objective is abandoned,
but another more easily achieved is substituted and this stuff is,
this is this.
These are the things that people,
people get the impression that well from me,
you just never give up.
Never compromise.
It sounds really cool to say that.
Yeah,
there was no,
there was no t shirt back in the day.
Sure.
It was four h and k rifles.
Yeah,
and it said in a world of compromise,
some don't.
It had a picture of like an entry team going into a building and of course you
hear that and you think that's right.
No compromise effort.
Yeah,
but here's the problem.
No compromise means if you don't win every single time,
you will get defeated and destroyed because you're not going to end.
The problem with that is you're not going to win every time.
You're not going to win.
Every argument that you have,
you're not going to win.
Every idea that you put forth isn't going to be the idea that gets selected and
what you end up being as a person that can't work anyone else.
Or you end up a person that has one chance at charging machine gun nest and you
go straight forward up the hill towards the machine gun nest.
And guess what?
Everyone does.
You,
you didn't achieve the mission and everyone is dead.
Now,
if you would have said,
you know what?
We tried,
we lost two guys,
we backed up.
Now we're in covered position and we're waiting for some reinforcements.
And when the reinforcement show up,
here's the plan.
We're going to put down covering fire.
We're going to maneuver around to the flank or we're going to get a heavy weapon
in here and we're going to shoot a bazooka at this thing,
whatever.
So this one,
he's the one in the book where it says,
um,
give up.
It's not giving up.
It's more like giving up on a certain says,
giving up does not always mean surrender.
Yeah.
So surrender is like I give up.
Essentially giving up is like giving up,
like just basically stop doing something that's not working kind of thing.
Right.
Yeah.
We had this question on the podcast is when is it okay to quit?
Yes.
Like defined this thing,
the definition.
That's kind of,
and I had the conversation with the guy that we both know who was,
was making a great effort in a business.
The business was not being successful the way he had envisioned it and it was
costing him a lot of money.
It was costing him time.
He was putting all of his efforts into it and
you know,
he literally asked me,
hey man,
if I shift to something else,
is that quitting?
And I said,
it's quitting but it's not surrendering.
And I actually said,
what is your goal in his goal was not to be successful in that particular
business.
His goal is to spend time with his family and set up a safe financial situation
for them.
And he kind of got his wires crossed on thinking that this business that he had
started was the mission wasn't the mission.
The mission was taking care of his family and spending time with his family and
he had was actually failing to do either.
So sometimes you have to,
sometimes you have to make those adjustments.
You have to quit.
You.
Just because you quit one plan doesn't mean you surrender.
In fact,
I would get mad at young seals when they would come up with their plan.
They'd use the plan to go hit a training target.
The plan would start to fail and they wouldn't adapt.
They wouldn't change.
They'd stick with their plan and I'm not a quitter.
We're going to keep going.
Oh really?
Okay cool.
We'll kill everyone that you have.
You can do buddy carries the rest of the night out here in the desert I got all
night.
So it's essentially re when it comes down to,
it's almost like an issue with the language cause like quitting giving up.
Like these are things that we're kind of trained to think are these are bad
things to quit and give up.
So all you have,
I mean in given what he's talking about,
you know,
like nowadays
I've heard people use the word pivot,
like the guy you're talking about with the business,
right?
Pivot.
Yeah,
I've got to pay a bit.
It's like,
well,
eat,
pivot,
quit,
give up.
I mean,
I'd rather use the word pivot because it sounds like,
hey,
I'm still on the,
on the mission,
on the path.
I'm just taking a different direction.
We'd have to come up with a legitimate what never quit,
which is what we're actually taught in the seal teams.
But then when you say you're never quit,
that means never surrender.
That's what,
that's what it really means is never lose sight of accomplishing and doing what
it takes to accomplish your longterm strategic goals.
That's what it really means.
But that doesn't sound as cool as never quit.
Yeah,
but then and then give up.
Same thing.
They're giving him up means like,
this is too much for me,
or I'm not willing to work hard through it or whatever.
That's what it feels like it means.
But in this book,
it doesn't mean that,
I mean,
here's a,
here's a little,
little dichotomy for me that kind of hurts.
And I know,
I think it's pretty much ego talking,
but I,
when I hear pivot,
I always think,
oh,
things aren't going so well.
Is that good enough?
You know what?
That sounds kind of a negative connotation,
which is,
which is not good.
I'm criticizing myself for even having those thoughts because you do have to
pivot in business.
You do have to pivot in combat.
You can't be like,
oh,
here's what we were trying to do and it wasn't working,
so we're just going to do it harder.
No,
you actually have to say,
hey,
this isn't working and we're going to make some adjustments.
We're gonna pivot yet.
And I think that's what that word was sort of introduced to that whole space to
mean because of all these different,
but then here's the thing though on the,
uh,
on the flip side of that,
some guys don't give up.
They'll straight up give up cause it's too much work and be like,
I'm going to take a new direction and it might be for the pivot towards on,
you know,
more of the more personal stuff or pronoun or some more personal things.
Meanwhile they surrendered their whole mission.
It too much work.
You know,
you can come as easy or quickly here what we're going to pin it or in a pivot
hard if we need to check
next.
Ability to accept a feat in such ways is no fault of character.
In fact,
a man who can take it and still do as best without bitterness is highly regarded
in the army and in civilian life.
But there are other ways of meeting to feet or disappointment that are
destructive in may result in psychological casualty.
The familiar sour grapes reaction is what happens in a man who has said his
heart so firmly on a particular achievement that he can't give it up and face
the fact.
So he belittles or runs down the very job he wants so much to have.
He says,
pilots are all crazy or fools and the whole flying game as a jip.
Do we have to talk to good deal,
Dave Burke about that one?
Could do no,
because,
and that,
that,
that definitely happens.
You know,
you get someone that's trying to achieve,
you don't even care about a black belt who's not even that big of a deal,
but cool.
Don't get one because apparently you're not sour,
sour grapes.
You know where that expression comes?
I do not.
Yeah.
So I didn't need it until I was well into adulthood.
So it's like a old,
what do you call them?
Little feeble.
I Dunno.
What is it when it's like a story that didn't really happen,
but it was a
super short,
so this Fox was hungry and I saw some grapes up on the vines.
Right.
And so the Fox,
I'm like Dang,
there's pretty high so and it's all good.
I'm going to jump up on me,
eat those grapes cause I'm on gay jumps up,
misses the great,
he can't jump high enough.
So he's like,
all right.
He comes back and he's like,
you know I just got to jump higher.
That's all.
So he jumps high,
even higher,
still can't still can't get him,
tries again.
Still can't get them again.
Still can't get him.
Finally gives up.
It doesn't pivot gives up and while he's leaving he says it's grapes were
probably sour anyway huh?
There it is.
Started to go.
I don't like that.
Continuing more likely to occur is a sort of symbolic running away through
feigned illness or physical defect defect.
A man faced with failure to pass an examination for a promotion or he has long
form,
may suddenly announced that he is colorblind or night blind or has some other
previously undiscovered defect that would prevent a success or he may become
actually ill and be honestly unaware of the connection between sudden sickness
and frustration.
This is a
feigned physical defect is a big one for people that don't make it through some
kind of military training program.
So what does that,
we're like,
well,
what happened?
I wrote my leg,
right?
Maybe they did it or we are.
So are they blaming something that actually is occurring or are they just sort
of make physical effect?
Hey,
I couldn't do this because my leg was hurt.
That's why I didn't make it through the program because I got this.
I got that.
Yeah.
Okay.
And then the other thing that they make is sometimes people actually get sick,
but it's because they're,
you know,
like the mind body connection.
Huh.
That's crazy.
Back to the book.
Each man,
no matter how strong mentally and physically has his limits beyond which the
strongest will cannot drive him.
The wise man learns his own tolerances and cautiously retreats if possible,
to a more defended position when hazards and obstacles.
He's in danger of our two.
Great.
Okay.
It's amazing that they so clearly understood this and this is 1942 or something
like that and they're saying,
look,
they're saying the exact same thing.
That's a big revelation to say pivot nursing.
The same
rage,
a two weapon,
a group of tanks stands in a field,
silent,
motionless,
any dead suddenly switches are thrown,
motor start and they become alive.
Noise burst from their exhaust and they roar to attack.
A gun is a nurse and dead until high explosive powder is set off and it's
chambers a bomb without Nitroglycerin is a dud.
All weapons are mere useless pieces of metal until the release of energy brings
them to life.
Yeah,
man too.
As a weapon of war must have energy release to galvanize him into acting,
fighting soldier,
and the high explosive that sets off a man's fighting power is emotion.
There are certain things that a man can do in an automatic way without the fire
of emotional energy,
but these things would win.
No wars without fear and without rage.
He could not even defend himself if the enemy were aiming at him and about the
fryer.
Slap a man's face and he will become enraged.
Drop a bomb beside him and he may become terrified.
But although the two feelings may seem different to made seem to the man very
different inwardly the changes that take place in his body or similar,
his heart beats faster,
his blood pressure rises,
his blood is shifted from internal organs to the muscles.
His digestion stop,
stops,
sugar in his blood,
increases his hands,
tremble,
his voice quivers the body wastes in the bladder or bowels may be expelled.
He becomes alert and ready for instant action.
Whether all this extreme preparation for action by the body as a good thing for
the soldier or whether it will eventually or whether we'll actually endangers
life depends on the circumstances.
When in primitive hand to hand combat,
when the last ounce of energy of which the body is capable must be summon
instantly for one tremendous spurt of running to get away from peril or for one
outburst of physical strength to down the foe rage or fear will pour into blood
the adrenaline it necessary to rouse that vital energy
if immediate vigorous action is impossible.
However,
and if life depends,
instead upon the cool headed use of skill,
self control and discipline than violent emotion can put the soldier in mortal
peril.
So this one thing can kill you or save you.
Yup.
Yeah.
It was an interesting differentiation there where it's like,
hey,
if,
if the task kind of requires like skill and stuff,
probably you got to control that you gotta you know,
you can't be doing it.
But if it's like,
hey,
if you sometimes,
because let's face it,
men in life and whatever,
sometimes it just brought you just kind of power through some stuff every once
in a while.
No,
no doubt about it.
And you know,
so and how you actually hear the way he said put quite eloquently,
uh,
what does it sometimes,
sometimes you have to use your logic and sometimes you have to use your logic
fails freedom field man,
this thing is in,
he's in the field manual sometimes if if your,
if your logic fails,
like if you can't think of a good reason to,
why should I do another set or why should I go compete in this thing?
You have to let your emotions get a little get in the game,
and then sometimes your emotions get shut down because you think Bruce is just
stupid.
This doesn't all make sense.
Yeah.
Well then you got to let your emotions go way mean.
It doesn't make sense because you're being weak and you don't like that.
None of that's bad.
Actually,
the logic one a lot of times is,
well,
it's more more dynamic I'd say,
because you can have full Kotton lawn and what'd you,
but I can have full conversations in my head and the working out one was a big
one where I'm like,
think about how you'll feel after that's going to be the benefit,
you know?
But then at the same time it'd be like,
Hey,
wait,
but you could easily restaurant now you can get recovered.
You know?
So it's like you're one of those guys that has a huge,
huge surplus of standing by things that are like,
look,
you know,
the most important part of working out is rest.
You don't,
you don't grow,
you don't get stronger when you're working out.
You actually get stronger when you're rested.
You got that little voice.
So you got that,
that one little monkey on your shoulder that's whisper and those things.
Yeah,
but now I got you.
Who in the big monkey,
even giggling because you and I got this from you essentially where it's like,
okay,
I can,
this is kind of the conversations going on in my head.
Um,
typically.
So yes,
I can be like,
yeah,
the recovery,
that's how you,
you know,
get the gains,
whatever.
That's on one side.
Then the other side is like waves,
but you want to train,
train a whole,
there's way more to working out than just getting bigger and stronger.
There's more to it.
There's mental exercises,
mental toughness exercises in there.
There's doing discipline all like all these things.
Oh,
yet and hand,
they're more like,
they're longer lasting.
Like things to try to develop,
you know,
like we need to develop them.
They applied it more things.
So you can be,
I can be,
I can easily be like,
hey,
I don't feel like it today.
That's my body telling me I should rest today.
Yeah.
I really don't feel like it physically.
And that is true.
It's probably true.
But what else is true is if I can train myself to power through these sorts of
situations,
even though they're true,
that's going to serve me way better in light.
So if you develop that skill out of this,
so I'm like,
Dang.
So now he got two months explaining some of that stuff to my youngest daughter,
my youngest daughter,
about how competent competition is good.
And the reason competition is good is because life is a competition.
It is a straight up competition.
And if you're not good at competing,
if you don't get comfortable with competing,
that's going to be a problem.
When it comes time to compete,
which you will have to,
you're not going to get through life without comp competing for things,
for whatever.
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't happen.
You're going to have to compete for a job.
You're going to have to compete for,
you know,
to,
to meet someone,
to be,
to be your wife or husband.
You're,
there's competition going on for that.
They're just not like down for the cause out of the gate.
Now you've got to fight off other humans to get what you want.
Whether it's a spouse,
whether it's a job,
whether it's a promotion,
whether it's a part in the school play.
Oh,
there's other people that are going to be trying.
I was telling my little daughter this,
you think they're just going to walk.
Step aside,
when you show up,
you want the lead role.
Yup.
You got it.
You know it's a competition and you must destroy the competition and the way you
do that,
as you compete,
you compete in different things a lot.
You push yourself and you figure out what it takes to step up.
Yeah,
like wrestling a lot.
Wrestling puts a lot of pressure on kids and it is straight competition.
Mono e mono or in the case of my daughter,
what does that female,
a woman,
well motto versus a woman.
No,
it is straight competition that you against another human being.
One of you's going to win,
one of you's going to lose 100% of the time.
That's what's going to happen.
And it's all on you.
Yeah.
So that's really good for,
for people.
It's good for kids.
Jujitsu competition,
same thing.
And then you just get,
you can just say any kind of competition,
you know?
Yeah.
It's like a,
well,
a dichotomy too,
you know,
in,
in the spirit of accuracy,
it's cut like life.
Not to get too deep here,
but life is,
is half competition,
half collaboration.
So they ain't gonna.
It could be different.
Could be 60 40 and whatever,
whatever.
You're a hundred percent competition for me and a bunch of collateral for you.
No,
but here's the thing where,
yeah,
you get people who lean to too far towards competition,
they start to alienate people and they can't maintain relationships like the,
all of these problems,
they're playing the short game.
Short game.
Yes.
And the collaborations,
if they're playing the long game,
that's not a factor because they're realizing,
oh,
I'm going to win in the long game.
Well,
so this short game is a sacrifice.
You no problem.
Oh,
is I want to,
you know,
I'm not going to do something that's going to create an antagonistic
relationship with these people that I'm going to count on in the future.
So guess what?
We're going to take a little hit right now.
We're going to make something,
you know,
we,
you make compromises because you're focused on the long game because ultimately
it is a competition.
Yeah.
Well it is a competition.
Sure.
Um,
not everything's a competition.
A lot of it is a collaboration,
but we then,
I mean most times we collaborate to compete.
Yeah.
So what I'm saying,
so it is,
it's like a little balance,
like a little dance you're doing with collaboration.
Competition.
That's why I think anyway,
I don't know.
But from what I can view or see,
observe that.
Yeah.
If you lean too much towards competition,
[inaudible] yourself up.
And if you can English teacher much towards collaboration as a dichotomy,
jam yourself up too.
It's like you can't,
you can't succeed.
It's like you can't get out of like your little clouds.
It should be balanced.
And if you are competing on things,
because there's people that compete on things that don't matter yet,
don't matter.
And the wall or they compete when they should be collaborating.
Yeah,
that's true too.
Or they're afraid to compete so they don't compete at all.
So there's all kinds of problems.
But yes,
I,
what am I,
I'm speaking a little bit simplified for my daughter because what my daughter,
when I want my kids to realize is that there is competition.
Yeah.
And that they're part of it whether they want to be or not.
That's the point that I'm trying to make.
And so when I talked to my daughter about something and she gives me a kind of a
shoulder shrug about something,
when it's not a shoulder shrug situation,
then you've aren't understanding that things are a competition and life is a
competition.
And you know what?
It is hard to say.
It's,
it's,
it's very extreme to say everything in life or life in general or life as a
whole is a competition.
That's a real extreme statement.
And I can see,
I totally agree with your point and you are correct that that can result in then
a bad,
a bad attitude.
And it really of not even just a bad attitude,
a bad life.
I mean,
you can end up,
like you said,
you can alienate everyone and you can end up alone and you're competing in New
York.
I beat that person.
I'd be that person.
And now when you're just,
you've lost.
That's the thing is you,
you,
you've lost a whole section of,
of your competition,
which is developing relationships with other human beings that you can then
count upon in your times of need or that you can provide for.
It's like all you've ruined everything.
So,
but what I'm saying is even that right there,
if you think about it in terms of what I just said,
you lost.
So ultimately to win the competition,
you have to be aware of it.
You have to compete and competing.
This is,
this is probably the crux of what we're trying to say.
Competing doesn't always mean
compete.
He's smashing the other person.
Yeah.
Competing doesn't always mean that sometimes competing means actually letting
the other person,
when you're competing sometimes means letting get compromising.
Because I'm going to win the long game.
I'm playing the long game over here.
Yeah.
And you're playing around with the short game.
It'd be,
it'd be,
hey,
good job.
I'm going to applaud you.
I mean golf clap.
Yeah man.
It's too,
cause at the end,
you know,
you can collaborate all you want,
but if you have like you put it the long game,
which is really,
really effective way to look at it by the way with everything.
But if you can be collaborating and be the,
you know,
the best team player in the whole wide world,
but your goal,
your goal is for your team.
If you're the team player is free,
your team to win whatever you're doing.
And when,
I mean it's,
here's the thing,
I think people get emotionally jammed up when they hear no,
everything's a competition and they shouldn't be like that or whatever to win in
life when me and that they think that like I win,
you lose kind of thing.
But really when it comes to even like just genetically,
right?
You know how they say,
you know,
finding a mate or reproducing whatever,
it's like you're,
it's like survival of the fittest,
right?
Darwinism kind of thing.
Like organisms compete for me,
it compete for this cause.
So it's kind of like that's how it is.
You know,
it's not like I'm a person,
you're a person,
I'm going to win and defeat you and you,
you're the loser.
It's not that,
that thing.
It's like basically you want to be successful and for,
for most situations,
for you to be successful,
you have to kind of,
you have to beat someone out of them then.
And in order to be successful,
you also have to play the game.
You also have to play the game by the rules.
Yeah.
Cause otherwise you end up ostracized or in jail.
Right.
Cause you could say,
I'm going to win.
I'm going to make the most money.
So why don't we know him to steal it from people.
Yeah.
Do immoral things in order to get there.
That that would be,
uh,
everything's a competition attitude.
But it's the wrong attitude because you're not going to win in the end.
We're going to lose,
you're going to be in jail.
So you lost.
But if you realize that it is a competition and you have to play the roles and
you have to win the game and winning the game means that you are successful in a
place where you can help other people and you've got what you need and that's
what we're looking for.
Yeah,
definitely dichotomy with that one.
Speaking of dichotomies,
going back to the book,
it is possible.
It is as possible to be literally blinded by rage as it is to be paralyzed by
fear.
A Prize fighter knows that he can win against a stronger and more skilled
opponent if he can rouse his opponent to violent anger in which he strikes
wildly and fails to use his science.
We see that all the time.
Got To maintain your composure in a fight on the maths,
even on the mats of justice for the Jujitsu.
Oh yeah.
Big Time.
You know what?
You don't what movie was like the,
the,
the epitome of that was a few good men I remember at the end.
Oh,
and he was like,
when he made them admit to it,
he did.
That's exactly what he did,
man.
Told him,
took him out of the game,
got them all riled up,
made them Batman knows good.
You can't handle the truth.
That's right.
That was a good speech though,
by the way.
He but he let the rage and the emotion cause a problem for him jammed him up.
He could have just,
he didn't have to do anything.
No,
he could.
He just kept his mouth
shut and be like,
yeah,
whatever.
Yep.
Didn't do it.
Tom Cruise,
Tom Cruise.
He played the game really well.
New to the TAC is emotions.
Yep.
Isn't it funny that if you understand psychology and human nature,
you can actually play it on someone and bring their own demise based on
something that they're going to do when you sell still?
It's crazy.
That's why it's important to understand human nature.
Back to the book of the main purpose behind all the long routine of military
training and the preconditioning of troops to simulate battle conditions,
to drill into soldiers fighting habits so deeply ingrained so intimately.
Second nature that they will persist,
persist in the face of the most overwhelming provocations to rage or panic.
Long practice in shooting Cooley at a target without undue excitement,
without blood lost makes it possible for the soldier to shoot calmly as at his
target.
When his very life and the safety of his pals are at stake,
his hand must not tremble.
Then his keen eye and steady nerve must not waver.
Fortunately,
men in civilized society have been trained since early childhood to control and
discipline their natural impulses.
For the normal adult,
it is entirely possible for intelligence to remain in command of his behavior
and for even recently acquired habits to be retained in opposition to the
instinctive impulses to run or drop his rifle and flail out with his fists.
There are many degrees of anger,
however,
and although the violently enraged individual may be at the mercy of the enemy,
a milder form of resentment,
of injustice and calm determination to avenge cruelty can serve to fill men with
the fighting spirit that knows no defeat.
The difference between this cool anger and rage is like the difference between
tempered steel and molten iron.
Oh,
that's a good one.
Like the difference between a raging torrent that destroys blindly and the
harness the power of a Niagara that can be directed intelligently to wipe out
the enemy such deep and controlled anger is not to be roused
artificially by any group before any group of men.
It is the automatic result of an unpardonable offense.
It rises like an unquenchable fire when a man's house is attacked,
when his wife or children are abused,
when his own native land is invaded.
Such anger can be used not only for actual killing of the enemy,
but also to provide the energy needed for work behind the lines.
A soldier who is determined to defeat the enemy will do anything that he feels
contributes to wiping out the flow.
Whether it is changing the tires on the truck or unloading shells from a pack in
case or policing barracks in his training camp,
he will fight at his job.
He will do that job well and we'll use his own initiative to volunteer for extra
duty to think up ways of doing his job more quickly and more efficiently.
Okay.
Anger is infectious and can spread from one person to another through personal
contact.
Just to see the flushed face and tense expression of a Rafi person may be enough
to stir anger in others.
The sound of anger in a raised voice or the sight of angry behavior is even more
catching anger spreads most readily when the beholder is sympathetic,
when he's able to put himself in the angry man's shoes,
when the person who is injured is one of us.
For this reason,
the rouse anger of a people is much greater and more moving than the sum of the
individual anchors within the group.
They reinforce one another.
Anchor,
shared,
controlled,
and directed to the single purpose of destroying the enemy is a powerful force
for survival and for a victory.
Anger as a gift
that a rage against the machine is indeed respect.
Bringing out quotes.
It goes on hatred of the enemy.
Makes Sense.
Okay.
The army is organized throughout for one single purpose.
Fighting soldiers must be fighting men with a fighting spirit,
but some of the acts of aggression by soldiers are useless to the war effort,
effort,
and actually dangerous to the army when competition.
Here we go.
When competition between companies or regiments turns into bitter rivalry.
When soldiers in town for a Saturday night pick corals with each other or with
the townspeople.
When race prejudices are permitted to develop within a camp or when officers
stooped professional jealousy,
the harmful results can be as bad as those dealt out by the enemy.
This is when life and I always say the enemies outside the wire.
Yeah,
this,
all those things are fighting inside the wire,
fighting against ourselves.
Such conditions make riffs in the solidarity essential to the fighting morale.
They cause a deterioration of discipline.
Produce a state of anxiety and insecurity among the troops and worst of all,
they actually drain off in ineffective petty squabbles.
The fighting energy,
every ounce of which is needed to bring victory.
The thoughtful leader,
knowing that no group or nation can long survive even is torn by internal strife
or dissension with its allies is seriously disturbed by any tendency toward
personal or factional friction within his command.
He well knows that victory can only come if the whole group puts all its efforts
into a unified cooperative battle against a
common enemy.
You always end up with these little
factions,
right?
And you have to try and prevent that.
You Ha you gotta,
you gotta Watch out for those because they sneak up on you and it happens.
And it happens in any organization though.
People start to relate to each other and then they pick a little common enemy
even with inside the wire.
It's like us against them.
Yeah,
that's true,
Huh?
Cause and picking a common enemy,
even on a social level,
whatever that that like promotes cohesion within a group.
Like I apparently from what I read is like gossip,
right?
There's a purpose for gossip.
Like if people gossip,
it makes them like bond.
It's weird.
Yeah.
No.
And actually there's this book talks about rumors.
You were going to talk about that.
What are the fruitful,
ripe terrain for rumors to grow?
For gossip to grow.
Yeah.
But the act of doing it with each other,
part of the reason,
part of the reason is if you and I need something to connect on when we'll just
make fun of this guy,
we'll talk smack about this guy and we kind of bond,
right?
If you hate this guy,
and I hate this Guy Ben in the gate when the gate saw you.
So,
uh,
and you know the,
and this says,
and you say that you should,
you should try to prevent those,
you know,
little um,
like what do you clicks or whatever I took it kind of is there,
do you think there's benefit to them actually for his benefit,
just on a low level,
low level,
there are benefits but it has to be balanced.
Because guess what?
I'm the task unit commander of tasking at bruiser.
I Have Charlie and Delta platoon.
I Want Charlie and Delta platoon to be competitive against each other so that
they're pushing to try and become,
try and make each other or try try and become their best so they can talk smack
to the other guys.
We beat you in this thing.
We did a tune that thing.
Okay,
cool.
That's positive.
I want that to happen.
What I don't want is delta will tune,
figured out a good standard operating procedure and doesn't share it with
Charlie platoon because we want to keep out performing them on this drill or
vice versa.
That's what we don't want to have happen.
So you've got to balance these dichotomies.
Yes.
And you want to have these little competitive groups and inside,
guess what?
Inside of Charlie Platoon,
there's squad one in squad too.
They should compete with each other and InsideSquad one in squad to InsideSquad
one you got fire team one and fire team too.
They're competing against each other.
And then inside that fire team you've got to swim pairs and they're competing
with each other.
So you want to establish that healthy competition.
But what you want to make sure is that it doesn't cross the boundary into
sabotage.
Yeah.
So it's like it has to remain at all times has the little mini competitions or
competitive situations,
you have to remain within the boundary of the team goal.
Like he can never cross over that,
right?
Like it has to be,
it all has to support team goal,
right?
Whatever,
whatever that means.
I can't ever be taking away from the fact that we have an unified mission to
execute and achieve.
We can never let anything undermine that goal ever.
And that right there
we throw around this term putting the mission first,
right?
Like,
Oh,
you got to put the mission first.
Like we throw that around.
But if you think that through to its ultimate end,
it is the most powerful force that you can have from a leadership perspective,
from,
from the way that you operate and the decisions that you make because you look
at some decision that it needs to get made.
And if you,
if you truly ask yourself the question,
okay,
how will this,
will this move us towards our objective in a positive way if it will?
Okay,
we're moving in the right direction.
It sounds like a day.
If it's not doing that,
you're,
it's the wrong decision to make.
And so it comes time to fire someone.
You're firing this person cause they talk back to you and they were,
they got a bad attitude.
Okay?
So then you ask yourself,
okay,
what does this do to our mission,
our ability to execute our mission?
Well,
the guy's a Turd and he doesn't know his job well and he's been slacking off.
Okay.
And no one likes him.
Guess what?
He's getting fired.
But okay,
wait a second.
I don't like him.
I don't like him because he rubs me the wrong way.
I don't like him because he's got a big ego,
which means he's brushing up against my big ego,
which is making me hold it against him.
And by the way,
he's come up with a couple ideas that were better than mine.
And I resent him for that.
And by the way,
he's asked some questions during my last brief that were really hard for me to
answer,
to kind of put me on the spot,
all these things.
And so I've racked those things up and I started and now I put together my
little click,
who's did?
I started saying,
Hey,
you know,
he does this and he did this on this op and all of a sudden I got a reason and
now I need to ask myself,
okay,
am I furthering the mission?
If I get rid of them,
who's going to replace him?
He has experienced who's gonna replace that experience?
He's another body who's gonna replace that other body.
And so if you make your decisions based on what's good for the team,
by the way,
what's good for the team is what's good for the mission.
You have a team to accomplish the mission.
If your team is dysfunctional,
you're not gonna accomplish the mission.
If your team has destroyed or part of your team has lost,
you can't accomplish the mission.
So if you really truly look is is what I'm doing a well,
what about your family,
right?
Your family mission is to provide for your family and take care of your family.
When you start looking at things from that standpoint,
hey,
really want to get this new car.
Yeah,
right.
I really like this new car,
sir.
Okay.
We know that that's an emotional decision.
Yeah.
Buying cars for most people,
emotional decision,
myself included Americans.
It's not even just Americans.
People who love cars.
I don't know if it's cause the advertising thing,
but cars represent freedom.
You have the ability to travel hundreds and thousands of miles on your own
accord and maybe you just need to travel to the grocery market,
but still a car gives you freedom and then the car in a deeper level is
reflection of you.
It's your,
it's your,
yeah.
This is,
it's literally something that you get inside of and when people look at it,
they're looking at the metal and steel version of you in your own mind.
This.
It's so it can be hard to drive a 1997 dodge grand caravan with an attack when
the duck tape on the on the window,
sir,
it can be hard.
The fires,
the fires in San Diego in 2003 where you here for those yesterday?
Port ash everywhere.
So that ruined a lot of paint if the cars were sitting outside.
So my 1997 Dodge Grand Caravan had all peeled paint look like,
just just horrible peeled paint.
It was like a dark red,
but then there was these flakes of clear stuff all over.
It fallen off.
So if you looked at that car and I saw that car as a reflection of me,
it was pretty,
pretty low reflection.
You know,
nothing against my brother's out there that are driving the de minivans props.
You got the family you,
but you make that your priority because what I could have done back in the day
saying say no,
what I really want to get,
whatever the,
the Ford f three 50 super duty duly extended king cab.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm oak trim.
That's me.
I want to look like that on the outside.
So then what is my decision making broad.
Do I need that vehicle?
I live in San Diego by the way.
I live in San Diego.
What do I do with my vehicle?
I drive to work.
I drive home.
I take my kids to the Jujitsu tournaments.
That's what I do with my vehicle.
Do I need an f three 50 super duty,
duly extended cab diesel,
7.3 power stroke engine going,
I need that.
I Dunno,
kind of.
No,
I don't.
So what is the mission?
What is the mission?
First of all,
we know that when I buy a car,
it's going down in value.
If I buy a piece of property,
buy a house,
buy a home that's going to go up in value over time.
Sure it might go up and down a little bit,
but over time it's going to go up in value over time.
My kids can have that in 30 years that that they don't want that Ford in 30
years that things barely even running in 30 years.
So what is my mission?
My mission is to provide for the family,
protect a family,
take care of the family,
set them up for success in the future.
What do I need?
Drive.
I need to drive a Dodge Caravan.
Yeah,
that's what I need to drive.
I understand.
So if you frame things correctly about what your broad mission is,
you're going to do better off.
You're going to make better decisions as a leader.
That's the way it's going to be.
Oh,
and by the way,
speaking of leaders here we go back to the book.
The most serious of all causes for an epidemic of dissension is the bad leader.
When as sometimes happens in any organization like an army,
men have placed over them.
A man they do not trust one who loves to show his authority and throw his rank
around or an unreasonable Martin net.
The whole outfit will be filled with resentment.
Since it is impossible.
Show this antagonism to the officer who is at fault.
The troops go around with chips on their shoulders,
daring each other to knock them off.
The only way to wipe out such an infection of dissension is to track down and
remove the cause.
If men believe they have a grievance,
even if the complaint is unjustified,
they should be permitted to tell their troubles to someone in authority.
If an officer gives them a patient hearing,
investigates conditions with a fair and open mind and explains his findings to
the men,
they will usually be satisfied.
Even in cases where it is impossible to do much to correct the objectionable
state of affairs.
This is such good advice.
Guess what?
When you're in a leadership position,
you're going to have people that are gonna complain about things that are going
to see problems.
And what you should do in those situations is lesson.
Listen to what the team has to say.
Listen to what that individual has to say.
Yeah,
get feed back.
That's what you should do.
Back to the book.
Just telling their troubles to a willing listener serves to get the air cleared.
And in cases where men make constructive suggestions for correcting conditions,
they will take in the organization a pride that they never had before.
So that Kinda tells you to do something or asked you to do something and gives
you a suggestion,
used it and give him credit.
These are reasons why for many years in our army,
any officer or soldier has been free to tell a grievance to the inspector
general sent periodically to each place where there are troops,
inspector generals,
like a internal affairs type situation,
but you shouldn't need to resort to that.
You know if you're a good commander and a good leader,
when the internal affairs people show up,
they get told,
hey,
everything's awesome.
They have no grievances to put out there because they already told you and then
you gave them an answer and then people say,
well,
what if I can't answer the grievances?
Will you figured out what the answer is?
If you,
if,
if my subordinate comes to me and says,
Hey,
this is,
we're not getting the right food out here.
Well I don't just say,
well,
sorry.
No.
I said,
okay,
let me see what I can do about it.
Hey,
this is what's going on.
By the way,
there's a lack of flights heading in this direction.
The supply trains are getting blown up by IED.
We have an alternate plan for food.
We're going to try and make it happen in a couple months,
but right now we kind of got what we got and now what do you say?
Screw you.
No,
you go,
okay,
I understand we're at war for crying out loud.
I understand I'm not going to get steak dinner every night.
It's not happening.
Even though we might want it,
we're not going to get it.
So here out those grievances
it some people get s concerned that if you start taking grievances from people,
then it turns into a bitch session.
You heard this word this term before the bitch session.
I'm actually in general not scared of bitch sessions.
I'm not scared of them because if you ask me a good question or you ask me a
question,
I should have an answer for it.
I'm the leader.
If if you're in my platoon and you have a question for me,
I should be able to answer.
If you have a bitch,
I should be able to give you a reason why that is occurring and why we either
can move forward with some kind of a corrective measure or why we cannot because
the following limitations that we're under.
So I'm not really scared of bitch sessions unfolding.
Have I seen them become unproductive?
Absolutely.
I especially see them become unproductive when we're,
when we start to like lose the conversation.
And if the leader,
if you ask me a question and I say,
because yeah,
you know,
if you say,
hey,
why can't we get better food?
And I say,
because
then you say,
because of what?
And I said,
because I said,
so now we're going to have a problem.
Now this bitch session just became unproductive.
If you say,
Hey Jocko,
we know we've been here for two months,
why can't we get some better food?
And I'm like,
you know what?
Right now I don't even know cause I,
I agree with you.
The food is pretty bad.
And I like food.
And so let me take a note here.
I'm going to write down what I've set it up,
the chain of command.
We can figure out a,
what's going on,
why we don't get,
have good food,
and B,
if there's a way we can possibly start making this happen,
I hear you.
Bitch is now subdued,
right?
The complaint has been subdued
because I gave you a legitimate answer.
I didn't even give you a solution by any stretch.
I just gave you an answer.
I just took your information and heard what you had to say,
which is legitimate.
I've seen
people where they,
they,
they send up a complaint and then they get subdued,
but then the,
the leader doesn't follow up on the complaint.
Like,
I don't follow up and actually go up the chain of command and say,
why aren't we getting better food?
That's going to be a problem.
Next session.
It's,
hey,
you said you were gonna do some,
what's the answer?
And I said,
well,
I,
uh,
but the bit,
now you're mad,
rightfully so.
And that's really it.
That's really the,
that what tells the tale.
Cause like,
okay,
so a bitch session,
right?
That'll,
I mean,
uh,
along with complaints come with what I think is more important than like the
complaint or the issue that's complained about more important is the motivation
to complain.
So let's say the food is junk,
right?
If I think,
if I'm mad about that,
if that bothers me,
whether it be,
because I think the food should literally be better.
It should be better right now.
I don't know why it's bad right now,
but I think it should be in that mix that bothers me at the very least that
produces a motivation,
a complaint.
But if the food can be just as bad,
but if I have an explanation,
I have no motivation to complain because they're not mad at that.
It's understandable.
So a bitch session will,
will develop when those feelings,
those motivations to complain or maintained or escalated.
So like if you're like swearing ward,
because,
because I said so I'm still mad,
totally throw,
I'm,
and I'm even a little bit more mad because of the way you said that to me.
So that's when those bitch bitch sessions will come.
Or if he get a couple of people making the same complaint and then another
couple of people like you know,
kind of refuting it or something like that word anywhere where there's emotions
kind of in one,
one key factor that you brought up is the is the building up,
right?
If you're constantly communicating with your people,
then the bitch sessions don't build up.
It's when you decide which one or you don't,
when you lock yourself in your own vacuum and you don't listen to what anyone
has to say.
And then once every six months you go,
hey guys,
we're going to have AI,
a Q and.
A.
If you guys have any questions for me,
you guys can come in and you guys can ask me questions.
Well,
these guys have been brewing up questions the last six months and they go,
they got some questions,
boy,
and they're going to hit you with a mark.
So you that if you want to prevent the bitch session from getting out of
control,
guess what?
Communicate with your people more often.
It'll take that question about why is it food so bad?
By the time it's six months deep and that guy's been eating crappy food for six
months,
you,
there's almost no solution that you can provide that's going to be good for
them.
And by the way,
you wasted six months of trying to find a solution.
So that's just wrong.
So you're,
you're already starting off with a f with in a really negative situation.
So communicate with your people a lot.
Don't be afraid if some people say,
what if they asked me a question?
I don't know the answer to.
Cool.
You say,
Hey,
let me write this down and let me run this up the chain of command and find out
what's going on with that because I don't know the answer.
What if they,
what if they ask me a question that
I don't like the answer to,
right?
I don't like this.
I don't like what I've been told.
What you as the leader,
as the leader and someone says,
you know,
I get told,
hey,
you're not getting food because we prioritized one of the other platoons and
they're getting all the stake,
which by the way would never happen.
But if they did that and then I,
and then someone says,
hey,
why are we getting this bad food?
And I go,
well it's cause they gave it to the platoon.
You know,
I,
I wouldn't say I would s I would answer the question truthfully,
which is like,
listen,
this is what's going on right now.
For some reason they gave the other platoon all the stake.
Believe me,
we have no greater champion for stake in this platoon than me.
I am personally flying to see the boss and I'm going to figure out what's going
on.
We will get steak.
You know what I mean?
As opposed to just being mad or,
or not wanting to give the answer.
We're trying to hide it.
[inaudible] what's going on?
Oh,
I don't know why we're not getting sticky.
You know why you're not getting steak.
Tell everyone.
Yeah,
don't the more open you are,
and of course there's a dichotomy to this too because we can go too far and
telling the truth.
We can tell people the truth about things that they don't need to know about.
Right?
Yeah.
So you do have to be careful about that.
You have to be careful.
You have to be judicious in telling the truth.
You have to make sure that it makes sense in accomplishing the long term
mission.
If I tell everyone that we're not getting food because we got cut off and we're
out here on her own and we're,
we have about three days worth of food and water,
and by the way,
we're not going to live and we're all gonna die,
so we should be happy with this.
That's,
that's,
that's not going to help my mission.
Now I could eat.
I could turn that into something that says,
listen,
well here's what's going on right now.
We're caught off and here's the mission of going to,
to undertake to make this happen.
It's probably not a great example,
but I think we all understand that there's times if you screw up a video,
if you put a video together for me and it's got the worst Christmas music to the
video,
another terrible example,
I don't just drop the hammer on you and say you suck at editing.
Even though I kind of think that at the moment.
Instead I say,
Hey,
I like what you put together.
You know,
maybe can you explain why you did this music selection?
Cause for me it's a little bit different than what I would expect.
Yeah,
thank you for that
check.
Going back to the book,
incidentally,
but most important I keep,
I keep adding emphasis to things that are literally not ms book.
So what that actually says incidentally,
but importantly,
it doesn't say most important.
I added that I did.
This is second time I've done that.
I've,
I've taken something to the next level even though just on my own accord,
hey,
you're funny or you're feeling that.
And so what it says is incidentally in parenthesis,
but importantly,
this method of dealing with this fat dissatisfaction cheats.
The fifth columnist and Saba saboteur who made lurk in the camp,
it is much safer for the army that men should pour their gripes into the of an
officer then that they should spill them in a beer joint,
in town or in any other place where outsiders can listen.
Another method of handling dissension and overt aggression is by punishment.
This is the chosen method of dictatorships and autocratic organizations.
Generally,
the method is commonly used even in America and most children have to learn that
when they feel aggressive,
punishment is not that far away.
So another thing you can do when somebody asks you a question,
Hey Jocko,
can you tell us why we're not getting any steak?
I'll tell you why we're not getting steak because you haven't worked hard
enough.
Guess what you're doing tonight?
KP duty or whatever.
You know,
like when I punish you for asking your question.
That's like what autocrats do.
Dictators do that back to the book?
Sometimes the soldiers troubles can not be attribute attributed to any one
person.
They are due to the conditions of war or of army life and ambitious and
energetic man may find himself so wound up in red tape that he can not do a good
job and organization may be all set to go forward to an objective but as
hindered by failure of supplies,
by shortages,
by weather,
no one is to blame,
which I kind of disagree with that statement cause I always you're in charge of
that.
If you're in charge of that and then guess what,
you should have figured out how to get the supplies there in time.
You should have figured out a contingency plan for the weather.
But what what they're talking about is sometimes things go wrong and continuing
on that this natural need for someone to blame and punish when things go wrong.
Responsible for much race and religious prejudice is also the cause for most
corals that grow up between allies and between one branch of the service and
another.
So when you have these interservice rivalries,
it's cause there's no one else to blame when you have organizations where the
production guys that the sales guys are selling stuff.
And the builders of the stuff,
the engineers that design the stuff aren't getting it to them in time.
When they're getting it to them in time,
that's fine,
but just the market is down and they start hating on each other when they should
be focusing on how to adjust to the market adaptations that need to be make made
or the market adjustments that need to be made.
Instead they're going at each other's throats.
Why?
Cause they're,
they're looking for someone to blame.
No one looked for someone to blame,
figure out what the problem is,
insolvent
back to the book and occasional individual in any large group appears to
contradict all the rules about how aggression was built up.
He will turn nasty when he's,
this is a really interesting psychological profile,
so I'm going to read this again.
And occasional individual in any large group appears to contradict all the rules
about how aggression was built up.
He will turn nasty when he is treated with kindness and becomes very docile
under punishment or frustration.
He is excessively polite and cooperative as long as he's kept in a subordinate
position.
But when he has put in command of other men,
he becomes tyrannical and overbearing.
Such peculiar behaviors often the result of two severe punishment of self
assertion or aggressiveness and Childhood.
This man is carrying around his own grouches and resentments bottled up inside
them.
He's deeply anxious to punish and hurt other people,
but as long as he is faced with the threat of punishment himself,
he retains his childhood fear of showing his feelings.
As soon as other people treat him decently and no longer appear like a threat to
him than his meanness lashes out.
People who have this curious reversal of normal reaction to other people's
kindness or aggressiveness often like to boast that they are tough or hard and
that they respect a man will stand up to them.
This boast is an explanation that fool's many people even including the
explainer himself,
actually the respect they claimed.
A fuel is nothing but an unconscious fear.
A secret fear that the rebellious subordinate will punish them.
Such men make poor leaders,
they make their subordinates angry and uncooperative.
They work best when alone,
and this continues on.
The good leader is not afraid of criticism from his subordinates.
Yeah.
Amen.
I guess is what I would say to that.
A good leader is not afraid of criticism from the subordinates.
He will encourage it as a constructive and cooperative way of eliminating causes
for resentment and dissension,
and he will use it himself and dealing with his subordinates.
But the criticism should be constructive and directed it some true cause of the
difficulty,
not some imagined evil or some harmless and defenseless person of the group.
It should not be a means of passing the buck.
Here's some rules for critics to keep in mind,
so when you want to start throwing darts at the old man,
one,
stick to things that can be corrected.
Don't criticize dead issues.
We're on ultra bull situations.
You ever know?
Some people just get stuck,
they get stuck on something and they'll just never let it go.
Hey,
that happened three months ago.
I get it was a bad decision.
We would I if I could go back in time.
I do it a different way.
I didn't.
That's the call that got made.
Here's the adjustments we've made from what we learned and here's where we're
going forward.
Are you good with that?
Yeah,
but I'm just saying it where I can go
to be specific.
Keep to concrete issues.
Say what three limit the issue.
Don't blame the brass hats or the in general.
Say who.
That's a good one.
A lot of times we'd just like to blame them,
right?
They did it.
Yeah.
Suggest practical solutions to problems.
Don't arouse emotion without suggestion.
What to do about it.
Say how five stick to facts.
Don't swallow rumors,
especially access inspired rumors.
Six criticized leaders or men for their acts and policies,
not for their personalities.
Seven put blame where it belongs.
Don't find scapegoats.
I was gonna ask ways.
I wonder why it's so like appealing for lack of a better term,
to blame other people.
Cause I mean,
I guess when you think about it,
it feels like
if I don't have to blame myself,
that's a safety thing,
right?
So we'll start there and then sure.
If someone will blame other things that are not people,
I got another weather or the,
you know,
whatever.
But it's like,
it's almost like it seems more satisfying to blame other people because I don't
know,
maybe because they would feel satisfying cause it takes the blame off of you.
Yeah.
But even,
even more than like blaming the weather.
Right.
Whether it's like,
it's almost like it's,
it's,
it's more satisfying because if I can blame someone else because someone else
has the capability of actively trying to get in the way of my success.
So it's almost like this is what it feels like.
I,
I'm just wondering.
Yeah.
Because I don't feel good about blaming anything or anybody or anyone.
So it could be cause yeah.
Cause you're really in touch with like,
you know,
that part of things.
But I'm just saying just by nature,
because it has to be a natural thing,
right.
It has to be like a natural reaction to something I would think,
you know,
in different people have it worse than another.
I would say that that's a,
that's a reaction that's not to natural.
And it's a reaction that you have to nourish and raised correctly in yourself.
Because when you,
when a little kid spells spills the milk,
when you walk into the kitchen and your daughter's sitting there and the milk is
spilled over,
she says,
you say what happened?
And she says the milk spilled.
Yeah,
she's blaming the milk and the inanimate object already and she's four years
old,
five years old,
right.
I'm the same way.
Everyone starts off that way.
It's,
it's a blow to our ego to,
to take the blame for things.
We don't like to do it.
So it's not like it's something you have to mature into.
It's something you have to figure out over time and the more you figure it out,
the better off you're going to be.
And I was talking with Dave Burke about this could deal Dave and he was like
really fired up one day and the,
the fire was coming and I forget even what,
you know,
how we got on this topic.
I actually,
I do think we were talking about a client that we have at echelon front and he
was trying to explain to them that everything like trying to explain to the
boss,
the CEO,
everything,
everything is your fault.
Everything.
And the guy like,
no,
I get it.
But
yeah,
no,
no.
Everything.
No,
no,
no.
I get it.
No,
no,
it's,
I'm,
I'm all about extreme ownership.
I get it,
man.
I,
that's a great book and a,
you know,
I'm definitely taking ownership of what's going on here,
but,
and there's always a,
but the market,
but the d the guys that I hired,
but the person that dead I partnered with,
but the person I bought the company from,
but it goes on and on,
but the real estate that we leased it,
it just goes on and on.
And guess what,
if none of those are your probe and none of those,
your fault and guess what,
you're never going to fix any of them.
So the idea that this stuff is 100%
your fault,
100% your fault that's going on in your team s that it's hard to get that
through your brain.
Anyone's brain.
Yeah.
It's weird.
He like he ever,
you know,
when you're a kid or something or whether you witnessed someone else do this,
will you do it where it's like,
let's say you lost something,
right.
And sometimes the first reaction,
who took my whatever,
what do you mean that's a seal curse.
So the seal curse,
if you lose something,
as soon as you say,
hey,
you took my,
or hey,
somebody stole my,
as soon as you say those words come out of your mouth and you're gonna,
it's gonna appear in front of you,
you can actually do it like two to find something that evolves.
He's buying,
somebody's going to do,
then you'll find it immediate.
That's probably my earliest memory in the seal teams of,
Hey,
don't blame people.
Is that right there?
Because if you can't find your sexy mar life jacket or whatever,
so we took my second mark.
Oh,
there it is.
There's a willing stencil.
The JKO stencils on,
on that one right over there.
It was underneath another one.
But yes,
that's something that we all do.
But it's like a natural thing to think because,
okay.
I said I have these,
these slippers at home.
Do you mean flip flops?
No,
that's the thing there.
There are negatives in Hawaii.
We cost the flip flops.
Slit Phillip's.
Exactly right.
But these are slippery slope kind of like you can just fly in and out of like
when you're walking and whatever.
And uh,
so flip flops,
like if,
let's say you're wearing flip flops or thongs,
slippers,
flip flops are,
so they're not that because if you're wearing socks,
which I haven't been recently,
cause it's kind of chilly but weak,
it's all wear socks.
So he can't just slide in and out of flip flops with socks on.
Not that good.
You know,
if I'm going to take out the trash or something like this.
So anyway,
I have these slippages a real comfortable too.
They're like just regular Nike,
like slippers,
whatever.
So when can't find them for him,
it's his moment.
You know,
there's literally like six or seven places that are far away from each other.
By the way,
in my house,
six,
seven places that they could struggle is real.
Yes.
Charles was,
my slippers are located in the far distance away inside my own house.
They're really far apart.
I look in what place,
number one,
they're not their place.
Number two,
they're not there.
I automatically go.
My wife took swearing my slippers or someone grabbed my slippers.
You know?
That's like the thing even more so than the,
you know,
the four or five other places that I could easily.
That's why I think it's a natural thing.
It is a natural thing.
Yes.
You are correct.
Blame something.
I've been saying that for the whole time.
You and I have been doing this podcast.
It's a natural thing to blame someone else.
Yeah.
That's why this idea of extreme ownership of actually taking ownership of the
problems that you have is very important and it's hard to enact.
Its not,
it's not comfortable.
There's no one,
even when people eat the book and they listened to every podcast and they talk
about it with their troops,
even then it's very easy to slide into an excuse and you blame someone or
something else.
And the problem with those excuses are they don't ever solve themselves.
They don't fix themselves.
You can control you.
So take control over everything.
Take ownership of everything so that you can make them the way that they should
be.
What's the dichotomy in this?
That's why we wrote dichotomy leadership.
Cause some people took that and said okay well I'm just going to do everything
myself.
Yeah,
there's an old everything.
So now I'm going to hit her.
But you know what?
Send me a script for the video you're making right now.
I want to review it.
Send me up.
What's it called when you like draw the pictures,
send me up stories.
Tell me a story board for your next video ownership.
No,
that's not what I'm talking about.
There is a balance.
Yeah.
So this question pit,
you have to keep it balanced.
So this question might not really care about the answer.
So is it easier to blame another person or just something else,
like,
okay,
original point.
And to me it's the point is other than matters,
I feel equally horrible.
I actually feel more horrible.
Blame blaming another person.
You seem to feel better about knowing of nursing under.
No,
I feel worse.
I feel bad.
I'm Brown.
I'm with you.
Okay.
Do you believe me?
Not blaming like something other than yourself.
It does feel really,
really whack.
Yes.
But,
and that's kind of the rule now you look after like four to six months of like
dealing with you in this stuff.
It's like you became like a rule subconsciously or whatever.
Um,
so easy to identify when other people do it too.
Yes.
We fully,
we're like,
well I was,
yeah.
And you feel it in yourself.
Even if you have the thought like you feel it.
But,
so I was,
I was thinking,
wondering,
and I guess it doesn't matter,
right?
Because the rule is the rule,
but is it easier to blame a person because it's more comforting?
I was saying the genius teacher,
it's easier to blame a thing because then it's free.
There's no guilt involved.
The weather was bad.
That's why we failed.
Oh,
the weather doesn't get mad at you cause you can where's?
I'm like a echo screwed up and dropped the ball.
That's why we failed.
You are going to be mad at it.
The weather's not going,
hey,
you got a flat tire.
That's why I'm late.
You should have left earlier.
No,
no,
no.
You're like,
that's blaming.
That's me taking ownership.
But it's easy.
But wouldn't it be more comforting to be like,
hey,
someone fly like let's say you,
you walked out to your car and your tire was flat.
Yeah.
He'd be more comforting if someone was actively trying to get in your way
because it seems more like,
okay,
that's why it got defeated by this situation,
I think to me saying,
Hey,
I walked out here.
There was a nail in my thing and you might take that one step,
but somebody left and down as soon.
I'm saying,
no,
I mean I wouldn't,
I don't think it would maybe hire,
you're sweating this distinction.
Don't blame other people or other things.
That's what you do.
You don't blame other people or other things.
I'm reveling in the understanding.
Don't revel in it.
Just do,
just take action.
Yeah.
Yeah,
you're right.
You're right.
And you know what we're going to wrap for today.
We haven't even,
we haven't even covered the major,
the one of the main reasons why I'm covering this book.
We haven't even got to yet,
so we haven't even gotten to it yet.
I,
I don't want to jump into it right now because
this is a book where I'm highlighting entire pages,
entire pages.
I'm just so,
I want to have time to discuss this properly and we will not have time to
discuss the rest of this properly today.
So one thing we do have hopefully time to discuss properly,
it's questionable because I know someone said the other day,
I said on the podcast,
a,
all we need to do is no,
just wrap this up.
And they looked at their podcast player and there was 47 minutes left,
and so it took you 47 minutes.
I'm blaming you.
I know.
I'm kind of,
I know,
I know.
I am at least partially guilty for lengthy sections of the podcast because what
I can't refrain from doing is making a little comment that spurns you to talk
about Hawaii five o other important topics.
So
we'll continue with this book next week.
Right now if you,
if you want to compete.
Sure.
In life.
Look,
I'm not saying you got to look at life as one big competition win or loose,
but I'm saying you should at least consider that that's kind of happening
whether you want it to be happening or not in that,
in that view,
you want to
get on a path,
a path of victory,
a path of discipline,
a path of winning.
And I know you have some things that might help us in there.
Yes sir.
I do Echo Charles.
So it is one of these.
So if you like the way you live your life,
right?
You're,
it's like you're preparing for a battle metaphorically.
You're rule or whatever,
right?
Sure.
You're not competing with me or with whatever in,
in every single little thing.
Right?
In fact,
you're a big part of what you do is collaborate with me.
True,
good.
Collaborate with other people,
but it's a,
we can win so we can win.
Exactly.
Right.
And in addition to that,
if you wake up just one moment and you're in the company,
the heated competition of whatever,
you're going to be more prepared to win.
Sin told few PR.
If you put yourself in stressful situations,
you'll be more prepared when the real stress comes.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
So let's say Jujitsu for example,
right?
Let's stressful situation you can put yourself right into.
Yeah.
So let,
let daily basis think about this too and where,
you know,
the whole collaboration,
competition,
balance goes give me,
and you were competing in Jiu Jitsu with each other.
When we train,
right.
Or,
or end,
we're competing with ourselves because you're using me to just get better in
general.
So sure.
There's a part of it that's like you're trying to do,
feed me whatever.
But the main part is you're trying to defeat how,
you know the,
the gut yourself.
Yes.
Beat,
you know,
a month ago or a day ago,
whatever.
Yes.
Trying to get better.
And to do that,
you have to collaborate with me.
Who's going to provide that stress on you see,
so it's always like,
I think there's always an overarching competition.
That's the life game.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
With varying levels of outcome.
Lots of little competitions along the way.
Some of them are important,
some of them aren't.
Some you've got to surrender.
Yeah,
because it's going to propel you further in the long game.
Some of them will feel like they should be a competition when they should be a
collaboration.
They should be okay.
Anyway,
back to Jujitsu.
Okay.
Jeez too.
We're doing,
we're all doing Jiu Jitsu.
If you're not,
then just due to just eat.
You have to,
you essentially have to to to know the path broadly.
One thing that's good about Jujitsu is it is also,
I talked about combat and war being a revealer.
Jujitsu is revealing to,
oh,
it feels about the things about yourself.
It reveals things about human nature,
real,
real things about your ego.
It reveals things about your temper.
It reveals a lot of things and it reveals those things about other people and
you start to be able to sense and understand other people better because you see
their reactions,
you see how they respond,
you see how they get through or don't get through trying situations.
It's really in.
So there is some really good benefits beyond the fact that you will get a good
workout beyond the fact that you will truly learn to defend yourself in bad
situations.
You will also learn about life.
Yes,
you will learn about people and you will learn about yourself.
Yes sir.
So go down to your local Jujitsu Academy and tell them you want to train some of
the digits zoo.
That's kind of abstract though though.
What you said what's true and like,
you know when you'll learn about life,
not abstract.
Sorry.
No,
no,
no.
You're right.
It's general though.
Here's,
here's some of the specific,
you know what if I told you I've learned more about life and people and myself
from Jujitsu,
then I have learned about self defense from Jujitsu.
And that's a bold statement.
I don't know what that might not be specifically true cause I don't think I've
learned a lot,
but I'm,
you learned so much about actually fighting.
Yes.
That's kind of what I just said.
Not really.
It could be fraud.
There's a lot,
but I don't want to exaggerate and lie.
Well,
here's why we say,
well,
here's why I started in,
in whether,
I mean,
I think you started before this event,
so okay,
so there's,
there is this family,
they said,
hey,
we developed this martial art,
you know,
whatever.
Is there a reason?
You're not saying the Gracie family,
it was gonna it was going to develop it into oak story,
but yes.
So the Gracie family,
they developed their martial art.
They were like,
Hey,
this is our fighting style.
It real fighting now.
So let's,
this is what we're going to do.
We're going to invite everyone from all around the world with whatever fighting
style.
No matter how big,
no matter how small the guy is,
whatever fighting stuff,
we can invite everybody to come,
come like fight.
No time limit,
no rules,
no nothing.
Just everyone's going to fight.
See who's fighting style is the best.
Right.
It sounds like an old school like movie or something.
Yeah,
but it's true.
Yeah.
Straight up happen.
99 1993 right?
Yeah,
Colorado.
So they come and hoists Gracie,
who's hundred 65 pounds.
Oh,
he's not 165 pounds.
He's,
I don't think so.
I think he was like one 62 or three actions.
Check with voice.
You'll see one two,
three one,
two four if you rolled with voice before.
No,
he's not small broke.
Yeah,
he's tall.
He's tall,
but he's thinner.
Yeah.
It then there,
but he's not like skinny and he wasn't skinny back then.
He wants to wait at least one 80 I'm going to give him one 80 what?
We'll talk to hoist and get confirmation.
We'll talk to some of our people.
I think one sixties yeah.
Anyway,
if he was one 60 I would have to check the scales.
Well,
nonetheless,
have you ever heard that they reasoned hoists was fighting and not Hixon is
because her voice was smaller and slender and look to less boots imposing,
didn't Hixon.
Yeah.
Who did look imposing,
right?
Yeah.
And that was kind of an added,
like more imposing.
Who looked more imposing?
Hixon Gracie or Ken shamrock and Shama Ken shamrock.
Loved real imposing.
That's why it was so shocking when hoists at 160 pounds apparently.
Tap them out.
Yeah.
So the store,
the store,
the facts go,
this is what happened.
You can watch it on the old videos.
So they called it the ultimate fighting challenge is what they called it,
the UFC.
Sure.
So Hoists Gracie surprisingly beats up everyone.
This wasn't the kind of like you have one fight in one night,
this is like four fights in a way.
If you,
when you go on,
you know,
no time limit by the way.
Full contact fighting headbutt like whatever the kick in the groin and whatever.
Anyway,
hoists Gracie beats everybody,
including Ken Shamrock who's like what?
And he was like two 20 she was at risk of 20 shoot fighting,
wrestling,
like just bad ass.
He went for a full block.
He went for a few lucky,
she's crazy.
She's got on top.
Yeah.
And hoist new to defend it.
That's even crazier,
you know,
go out and talk and choked him up.
And then guys like who,
I don't think people talk enough about this Guy Pat Smith and he was Patrick
Smith,
obesity bare knuckle kickboxing champions like 250.
And know that's what it said on the,
on the video.
Um,
tough,
bad ass beating guys up real bad.
In fact,
he beat this,
this Ninja guy up on UFC two.
And I was like,
as a kid watching,
I was like,
Dang,
that's like,
this is brutal man.
This is like scary,
brutal.
And um,
nowadays that's nothing.
You know,
you're under,
you've seen us do nothing.
But nonetheless,
it was brutal then and hoists Gracie beat him up and hoists Gracie beat him up.
He,
he didn't do a submission hold on him.
He just had him in the mouth and just punching.
He tapped due to strike,
you know.
Anyway,
so the point is hoists Gracie with Gracie Jujitsu,
which is Brazilian Jujitsu.
It's interchangeable nowadays.
Beat up everyone proving that it's like the ultimate fighting style.
Yeah.
So that's why that's the number one reason I think most people come into it too.
That's definitely a good reason.
I think,
well back then I would say this,
that's the number one reason in 99319941995 white people want to do Jitsu.
I think Jujitsu now is,
I think Jujitsu as a whole is more popular.
You can get you to from anywhere.
I mean at wrestling tournament there's all kinds of kids day walking around
Jujitsu,
tee shirts on.
They didn't even,
they weren't even close.
They weren't even,
they were 12 years old.
Yeah.
And now it's to remember 1993 think about something that happened,
whatever 20 years before you were you born in 77 think of something that
happened in 1957 I can't think of one single thing.
And that's what I'm saying.
That's when the first UFC happened against kids 20 years before they were born.
They don't remember it.
It's not even a thing.
But what they do remember is like,
oh,
some kid down the street knows how to fight.
He choked me.
I want to learn that.
Yeah.
Well if they're watching ultimate fight night last night or the other night or
whatever,
and they saw crone,
Gracie,
yes.
Choke out the guy in UFC in the first round,
someone's going to join two to three cause that anywhere.
That is true.
Yes,
that was true.
A beautiful display of Jujitsu.
Very chrome.
Gary from Kron Gracie.
Yeah.
And that always feels good.
Cut It because it's a reminder because it's easy like now,
cause everyone knows that you did,
you know,
varying levels of whatever in UFC.
But when you get a guy who like so good at Jujitsu,
every once in a while like heal and Damien Maia would do this to where they'd
remind everyone,
like how powerful,
if you're just really good at Jujitsu and,
and the other guy doesn't quite have those elements or whatever,
it's really reminds me and lender dean lister.
He reminds me of that a lot.
Yeah,
for sure.
Nevertheless,
well do we need you to,
and we need a Gig.
What did he do?
We get,
we get origin.
He's made America,
you know,
from the cotton all the way up to the game in America for Jujitsu,
not many other are martial arts as well.
Just for Jujitsu specifically,
not [inaudible].
They're not made for Iq for Jujitsu made in America.
They're,
they're the best geese.
Straight up.
There's not even any question about that one origin,
mean.com that's also got a rash guards,
rash guards.
If you won't need rash guards for your Nogi situations.
I got t shirts,
sweatshirts,
jeans.
He just sent me a picture of genes coming off the rack there in production at
this time.
Jeans.
So be ready to get jeans.
Also supplements from origin labs,
best kind of supplements,
the kind of maintain your joints.
Joint Warfare.
I strew I incurred a hip injury.
Um,
yeah,
the other day and it's really bad that night.
So it,
oh,
I don't overdose.
Can you overdose on joint warfare?
I'm not sure.
I haven't tried.
So add just one pill.
Usually I take,
how many did you take at night?
Three.
Take three a day.
Okay.
I take three in the morning.
Three at night.
Okay.
So I went to and two.
And I'm like,
I'm just going to do this or whatever.
And it was surprising the difference between night one of the injury and night
two of the injury was surprising given how the injury fell.
There you go.
So this is the,
yeah,
so joint warfare and these are the,
now I think these are the most important kind of supplements.
There's,
I think I agree with you.
Joint Warfare,
Krill oil discipline and discipline.
Go
when you need a little bit of
need to get me to know you need to get up on step is what we call it in the
teams.
Well and what that means is you're in a little Zodiac boat and the Zodiac boat
going across the water with a 55 horsepower engine.
If you're out on the,
on the west coast,
on the east coast,
they use a smaller engine on the west coast or you use a big 55 horsepower
engine cause you're out in the Pacific and the waves are freaking huge.
But the reaches a point where it kind of the,
the boats like trying to push.
And then it gets on the,
it's in the water and then it gets kind of on the surface of the water and all
of a sudden he goes,
where there and then you're going fast.
You're on step,
getting on step.
I don't know where that comes from,
but Zodiac.
So it's like the perfect zone where the water catches the water,
the boats drag.
Yes.
It's the minimum amount of drag for the boat.
And that's what I feel like when I take discipline.
Go.
That's it.
You got to go.
I'm going to meet with someone.
I take like,
you know,
in a meeting I'm going to be working with a company,
takes some discipline to go get the mind firing correctly.
That's up.
Don't forget about moke additional protein,
additional protein and delicious.
Well,
you can call it additional protein or you can just call it dessert and straight
on yesterday I had three scoops of where your kid strawberry milk and I was just
sitting there drinking it and being happy about the whole world.
Guilt,
three guilt.
But Hey,
look,
can you,
can you can have beverage make you happy to be alive?
Yes,
Warrior cake,
strawberry milk can make you can,
you can make you happy to just be in the world and just be looking in beach,
sipping on it and being and having a whole,
a whole big cup and you're just,
every sip is you're not,
you're not even uh,
what's the word?
You're not even rationing yourself at all.
It's just wait,
sipping,
just free form.
Just as much as you can put in your mouth.
Like just beautiful strawberry milk and are really getting crazy now where I'm,
I've,
I'm really scatterbrained.
I'm like peanut butter milk.
They can,
all right.
So anyways,
that's that very good.
All that stuff is@originmain.com also Jocko was a store,
it's called Choco store and that's where you can be on the path for sure.
Be on the path requirement but if you want to represent while on the path but a
Jocko store.com got some cool shirts on there,
more rash guards,
you know,
more representative of the path.
Specifically some hoodies on there,
some hats.
Yup.
Truckers and stuff specifically or flex fit,
whatever you like,
Bro.
Both however you want to represent and here's the thing.
Look,
I don't,
I don't know if I'm going to put zip up hoodies on there.
I don't know.
I think so.
That might not be your thing.
They better be so thick.
Maybe they'll get the whole world,
the whole world stops and says,
hmm,
if I was in somewhere cold,
I would wear that because the whole world will say has actually that makes
sense.
If you go ultra thick with the zip up,
the reason you want zip up his cause you got other clothes on.
It's an awkward taking it on and off,
over overhead.
That's why he got the zip because it's a real heavy duty.
I prefer the Zip light or heavy.
Yeah,
but you prefer the pullover as you indicated.
One point I like to pull over,
if we're talking about w you know,
medium weight,
but if we're going to ultra heavyweight,
which no one has showed me ultra heavy weight,
I want to see ultra heavyweight.
I want something that actually is hard to pick up kind of
physically.
Nonetheless,
I think I'm going to go with some zip up stuff for Jocko store.
Look good at it.
That's what I think.
And brainstorm as you brainstorm that.
Let me see the samples and let me talk to the producers of the fabric so I can
make sure that it is the heaviest and most durable and warm mist fabric.
All right.
Oh well it's a promise.
All right,
there it is.
It a,
again,
it's that Jocko store.com gone there.
He liked something.
Get something good way to represent while you're on the path.
Also Jocko white tea if you were are a tea drinker or not a tea drinker,
still drink Jocko white tea for various reasons.
So I gave some of this to my neighbor.
We're doing some things,
you know,
and uh,
she goes,
oh my gosh,
yes.
You know,
like it was the one in the camp.
Um,
so my wife gave her three of them and she's like,
oh my gosh,
thank you so much.
This is so good.
And it's so hard to find t and a can that's certified organic.
That was the front running thing for interesting.
So I'm like looking at her like understanding that she has no idea that she can
like deadlift 8,000 pounds or you know,
like all these other added benefits.
But nonetheless,
it really demonstrated how fast the,
uh,
benefits,
you know,
and the,
it's kind of a weird perspective to have on life when you,
when you rate certified organic over a guaranteed of dead lift of 8,000 pounds.
Now clinically,
you know,
it's crazy little bit strange nonetheless.
A after you know,
a little bit of thought.
I understand.
Cause you know,
there's a nice lady who lives next door and um,
you know,
I dug it either way,
but one of the added benefits was brought to the surface and I liked dish room.
Speaking of,
uh,
benefits,
subscribe to the podcast to which we were going to stop saying until it was,
people noted that they didn't subscribe to the podcast until echo actually set
it on podcast 164 or no,
163.
And someone's like,
I listened to 163 podcasts and hadn't subscribed.
So subscribe to the podcast or echo will keep telling you to.
And don't forget about the warrior kid podcasts.
Lagging lagging on the warrior kid podcast.
And I got told by young Alana,
you know Alana?
Sure I got told by Alana's Dad said he,
she's like,
he said she has memorized the first whatever it is,
21 podcast.
And I said,
I looked at her and I said,
I'm sorry,
I'll make more.
And she said,
it's okay,
but she didn't mean it.
I don't think she meant it.
I think she was Kinda like
just being nice.
She's a nice girl.
I don't think she wanted to say,
yeah,
you should if some more podcasts because the first 21 are getting worn out.
Warrior could podcast a good podcast for kids to learn a really solid lessons
about life.
Don't forget about the warrior kids soap,
Irish oaks ranch.com where Aiden,
who's a warrior kid is making soap,
got his own business.
He's 13 years old,
he's got his own business,
he's got product moving,
he's shipping stuff.
He's got credit card.
What does that thing called?
The credit card system.
Oh,
like the,
yeah,
the point of sale system running.
You're 13 years old at a point of sale system running.
Got Production,
got manufacturing happening.
Hey,
it's soap.
Is it an iPhone?
No,
but you know what?
What were you doing at 13 years old?
You weren't,
you didn't have a manufacturing line set up?
I don't think so.
If you want to support kid,
a kid warrior give that's getting after it,
Irish oaks ranch.com and get yourself some soap so that you can stay clean.
You know youtube videos.
Yes.
If you like watching youtube videos,
that's not good.
You probably don't need to watch youtube videos of their distracting.
They take up a bunch of time.
If you do feel the need,
you might as well watch this youtube video of this podcast or the smaller
excerpts of this podcast that are clipped out or you can even watch echos.
Legit videos,
which are videos that echo his modified with CGI.
Straight up,
straight up CGI,
Chinet image,
computer generated graphics.
That's what echo is good at.
That's his thing.
He's good at that and he's going to curls
not as good as I was before.
So subscribe to the Youtube Channel and then you can watch all these videos.
Psychological warfare,
don't forget about that.
Echo is just know showing me a funny thing on the gram,
the gram Instagram of a girl that was lip sinking,
a psychological warfare video and I have to say it was awesome.
I'm going to try and find it and put it out there so everyone can see.
This girl was super fired up and good at lip syncing.
Yeah she knows like spot on.
Spot on.
If you didn't know you or her like you'd be like,
Bro,
this girl's voices weird.
You know,
cause she has your voice with it cause it's,
it looks really good.
She did a good job with that.
Psychological warfare.
Little assistance getting through moments of weakness in your day.
I'll tell you what to do.
I'll tell you why you should do it and then you'll go do it.
Psychological warfare,
iTunes,
Google,
play,
MP,
three platforms.
Check it out.
Give some also for
legit fitness gear while you're still with developing your home gym,
which we always are.
I still am.
This is where you get your stuff.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash jack or a lot of good stuff on there.
I just got a storm trooper.
Oh wait,
I told you this last time.
Okay,
so I made a mistake.
So storm troopers are not clones.
Stormtroopers are like individual humans.
Yeah.
That they raise from kids or whatever.
Clones are,
uh,
the clones from McClone war who came from bubble fit or Jango Fett.
One of them.
Once again,
Bro,
you're out of my league.
Yeah,
well I was talking about him.
I got scolded by my brother and various people for not knowing the Charles
jumped on you like you just,
he was literally listening to it in my presence.
I didn't know you was,
he got into it.
She paused.
He's like Bra and I'm going to hit on one of these,
you know,
kind of like us,
like Ooh.
It was like that Cayenne and
resort and he was,
he was mad nonetheless.
I still got the storm trooper kettle bell,
which has nothing to do with any clones.
It's just dope.
And it's a kettle bell,
which is good for,
you know you're working on and stuff.
Anyway,
I got it from on it.
That's where they have the best,
the best kettle bells,
the best stuff.
Go on there and get something from there.
It's really good stuff on it.com/jock
we also have some books.
What kind of books?
Well books for reading,
I guess you might say Mike in the dragons.
How'd you like Mike in the Dragon?
Snouts Denny,
how often do you read it?
So I re it's not on any kind of rotation,
but I've read it three times
to the children.
Yeah.
And did they support?
So you know what's funny,
they live,
not only do it like reading it,
they like watching the video,
which,
and I'm working on the whole book video,
so when I work on it or whatever,
they,
you know that
I'm not always uninterrupted.
We'll say that.
So they'll see me working on that.
Then I get constant interruption cause they want to watch it.
They want to see it,
but it,
I mean I,
I dig it because it is fun.
Really good book.
Mike and the dragons,
a little lesson,
four kids in that book.
It's probably meant for a little bit younger ages than the other kids books.
I've written way the warrior kid and weigh the warrior kid to Mark's mission and
now we have way of the warrior kid three.
I'm trying to get that up for pre order on Amazon.
The subtitle is where there's a will and some challenges presented to mark in
this latest book.
Thankfully uncle Jake is around to guide him and show him the path.
Also we got discipline equals freedom of field manual.
It explains all the people that ask what you work out,
what did you eat,
what time did you sleep?
All those questions are all in there and then all the questions that are,
how do you,
how do you get out of bed?
How do you,
when you want to procrastinate,
what do you do when you're tired?
What do you do when you're angry?
What do you do when you're afraid all those questions and put all those
questions in one big book,
it's called the discipline equals freedom field manual and it's a book that you
can give to someone and they will be happy and they will not.
They will.
They will get more from the book
then just a good read you.
They'll get a little shift in their perspective in life and they might even
hopefully get themselves hadn't down what we like to call the path,
the path of discipline.
I think you were right about that.
When you say that it's like the book that you sort of wish you had.
Oh for sure.
I would say maybe not when I was like a teenager because I don't think I would
have had the capacity.
Yeah.
Except you know this but like young adulthood,
maybe like 2123 ish.
Yup.
That'd be like man.
And what's crazy is I've got people that are 54 the,
one of the coolest things was I,
I met a woman at the muster,
she was like 55 years old and she was all excited.
She saw me and she's like,
hey.
And I was like,
Hey,
and we were working out and we got done with a workout in the gym or something?
No,
no,
no.
In the yes.
And she says to me,
she says,
you know why I'm here.
And I was said,
actually,
I have no idea why you're here or how you got here.
And she was in Costco or Walmart or target and saw the discipline equals
freedom,
freedom field manual.
And she just looked at it and said,
I'm buying this.
I don't even know what it is.
A mind.
And got home,
opened up reddit next day,
gets up at four 30 in the morning,
starts working at like,
that's what we're talking about from zero.
This is a person that doesn't know anything about me,
about the podcast,
about any of the other books.
Just that one book picks up and says this,
I'm just gonna get this.
And she was fired up.
She,
she lost weight.
She's just crushing things.
So that's a good book to get for yourself.
It's a book that I read.
It keeps me on the path.
And if you want,
the audio version is on iTunes,
Amazon music,
Google play,
other MP3 platforms.
There's obviously extreme ownership.
First Book I wrote with my brother Leif Babin,
it's about leadership.
It's about the leadership principles we learned in combat and how you can apply
them.
And then I talked about dichotomy of leadership today because sometimes we can
take any principal and we can go too far in one direction or another that can
cause major derailment of your organization,
your team,
your life.
So read the dichotomy of leadership so you can know and understand and recognize
the pitfalls of going too far in one direction or the other.
On top of those two books,
we've got a little company called Ashkelon Front.
It's a leadership consultancy in what we do is we solve your problems through
leadership.
That's what we do.
Whatever problems you're having in your organization,
those problems are leadership problems.
Nope,
no matter what those problems are there.
Leadership problem,
that's what they are and if you want to get those problems fixed,
go to Ashkelon front.com and we'll be in touch.
Also the muster,
which is a leadership conference 2019 we got May 23rd and 24th in Chicago.
We got September 19th and 20th in Denver.
We got December 4th and fifth in Sydney.
All of our shows we've ever done have sold out.
These are going to sell out too.
If you want to come to them,
go to extreme ownership.com and work it out.
F Online,
just launched online in January.
If you can't come to the muster,
if you are living in a situation where you can't come to the muster,
you can't afford the muster,
but you really want to get the information from the muster.
Awesome.
You liked extreme ownership and you want to get more out of it.
You like listening to the podcast and you want to dig a little deeper.
Awesome.
All those situations is why we made something called e f online at a company 18
months ago.
Guy Said,
hey,
I want you to train everyone in my organization.
I said,
yeah,
do it.
No problem.
And then I was like,
wait a second.
How many people do you have?
87,000 globally.
Guess what I,
I was like,
okay,
let me,
let me get back to you cause I humanly physically could not do that.
So I had to think about how we're gonna scale this thing.
We talked to les from like let's Go,
let's go digital and is a little scary because in the navy we did like the
digital training,
sometimes online HR type training and it was a lame and so I was nervous about
it.
But once,
once we saw the new technology which exists,
which is awesome,
that's what we did.
So we spent the last year putting it together.
It's interactive,
you do role plays,
you put yourself in combat situations as a leader,
you put yourself in business situations as a leader.
You got frequently asked questions,
you got all kinds of choose your own adventure scenarios that are your fault and
you get the briefings and explanations and details around the principles of
combat leadership.
It's all in there.
So if you want to check that out,
it's at e f online.com online.com and also we have f Overwatch where we are
finally taking
combat proven leaders from special operations and combat aviation and we're
putting them into companies that need leaders that understand the principles
that we talk about in the books and on this podcast.
So key F,
overwatch.com is where you go.
If you are either someone that's looking for talent or someone that's looking
for a change of careers after you're done with your military career are waiting
for you there and if you want to talk to echo and I more if the,
if three hours wasn't enough,
if you need to tell us something else or you want to tell us something else or
you want to ask us something else,
that's cool.
We are
okay
on the interwebs.
We are on Twitter,
we own Instagram and we are on that.
It Echo is adequate.
Charles and I am at Jocko Willink and of course thanks to everyone who is out
there in uniform holding the line.
Okay.
Our military personnel,
police and law enforcement,
firefighters,
paramedics,
EMT,
correctional officers,
border patrols,
all you first responders.
Thanks for everything that you do to keep our safety and security in tact.
And to everyone else that's out there listening.
Remember what this book said and that's,
remember that real defeats other than death itself are psychological in nature.
And that the important contests in life itself are psychological in nature.
So know who your dealing with.
Know who you can count on,
know your enemy and what his strengths and weaknesses are.
And most important know yourself.
No your own nature.
So you can avoid the pitfalls that we are all susceptible to know yourself so
you can stand up in any situation and keep getting after it.
Yeah,
no matter what.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.